I'm sorry. It's just funny. So then he's down and then he gets
back on. He gets back on the side of the
back on the side of the here. He like kind of jumps on.
Is he getting off?
Hold on. >> The best course of action is just getting your
weapon. Yeah, I know the best course of action, but I want to
each and every one of these guys >> in GTA. >> No,
I want to Well,
>> no. In real life, [laughter]
though, I think Clvicular is the way to go on this one. Now,
I'll say I don't think I've seen very much of this. I saw a little
bit of his reaction and just people talking about it, but I didn't
get to see like the original [__] So, I'll go through
some of the clips, we'll talk about it, and then we'll try to
figure it out. I think the contrarian take is like Clavicular
did nothing wrong. I don't know if that's real, though. Okay,
so let me take a quick look. Okay,
so apparently we're going to go through the history of Clvicular
getting stream sniped before this. Okay, just to get some flavor
on it.
Just get some some flavor here. Okay, so Clvicular ends stream
after getting pressed and jumped by the same gang that attacked
Ed Matthews and abducted a girl. This looks like the guy again.
This is the Darius lookalike. Okay, this is the crackhead Darius.
All the gropers got his back. A white Chad driving over a black
delinquent is great optics. Okay, Norah Blaze, I need you to
stop coping and pretending
that this guy isn't the actual average skin gradient groper.
Okay, can we can we stop pretending that this guy isn't just
your main demographic for two seconds?
Clvicular is not your demographic. This guy's your demographic.
If you're a groper,
just be real for two seconds. Okay, John Bravo. Uh maybe we'll
check this out. Maybe we'll check out some other reactions.
I'm sorry, but this is literally the primary Groper demographic.
This looks like every Groper I've ever seen stream snipe somebody
ever.
>> We work hard FOR OUR PEOPLE. WE WORK HARD FOR OUR DON'T
CALL MY [__] DON'T [__] touch me. Don't
[__]
me. Don't put on me. Don't put YOUR HANDS ON ME. TOUCH ME. Put
your hands on me. Don't touch me. I don't give a [__]
Don't touch me. WHY YOU TOUCHING ME? DON'T TOUCH ME. Put your
hands down. >> Don't touch me. Just go.
Don't touch me though.
>> Dude, I saw I saw some clip of Clvicular
talking about how he used to do Tren like a while back. He he
was doing Tren and how he just got like mad and knocked people
out. And it's like, bro, I've seen you a year ago. You're like
a chubby never been outside white kid like a year ago, like a
year and a half ago. What are you talking about? You were knocking
people out. When were you knocking people out? When were you
on trend and knocking people out? Was that like a oneweek period
of your life? He started when he's 14 apparently. Okay. Okay.
[screaming]
>> That's all we want. Release the [__]
>> This is the guy you need to keep an eye on. Okay.
>> Can we please continue with the rest of our night? >> You're
so beautiful. Wait, who? Wait, who are you to him?
>> Take a step back. >> You his girlfriend. Why are
you touching Stop touching my breast?
Why you touching? >> Don't Don't take any more steps. Stop
touching me. >> You're not taking a step back. >> We
work hard.
>> Gorers should hate this guy. No. He made Nick do those
gay Tik Tok clips. No. Gropers are very forgiving of Nick being
like extremely attracted to clvicular. I don't I don't think
they really have a problem with it to be honest with you. Nick's
funny. He's allowed to be eccentric and kind of queer at the
same time. Okay. That's just that them's the brakes. Them's the
rules. Them's the brakes. I don't know. >> Get off the
prop. >> Okay. Hold on. more of this is sweater god pulls
a pulls gun on stalker that came to his house on stream. Wait,
>> Oh, this is a different stream.
>> Get off the property. >> I want to gamble with
you, >> bro. Get off the property, bro. >> Oh, it's
the same guy. Bro, what what's with this Charlie Manson ass tattoo?
>> Get off the I don't care that, but I just want to gamble
with >> Bro, get off the property.
>> Can I gamble with you? >> No. Get the off my property.
>> Are you
>> How many Let's be honest. How many streamers saw Darius
for the first time and thought it was this guy? Like just didn't
want to interact with Darius at all cuz this crazy stalker dude
was walking around Austin, Texas.
>> He smacked over,
>> Get off.
>> Get off the property.
[laughter]
Get off the
Dude. Jesus. That's pretty [__] wild. Okay, there's
no way this is all the same guy, is there? I've got a couple
of these, but there's no way it's all the same guy. >> What's
up? What's up with it? >> That's That's not Clvicular,
is it? >> What's up with it? Let's go. Let's go right now.
Let's [__] go.
>> Let's go.
>> Come back. Come back.
>> Dude, this can't be Wait, this has to be California
or something, right? There's no way people are out here doing
this in
>> What? Deleted footage. A stream sniper pulls up to Kicar's
Clvicular's house and instantly regrets it. That's not him, is
it? I get how that could kind of look like him. Is that him?
Is it not Florida? Oh, it's Florida. Okay, dude. I'm just saying
like if you even if somebody's like coming to your house and
you pull a gun out, I feel like that's
now you're on the same level. No, I feel like under the law,
would you not almost certainly be on the same level? Like you're
going to kind of harass somebody at their house, they pull a
gun out. Are you not allowed to go? Oh, and pull a gun out, too.
Clavicular.
Clvicular.
Nah. Clav. We'll just do Clav. You're on your property at your
house. Okay. All right.
I mean, I understand castle doctrine a little bit, but I thought
basically once you've got a gun out, when somebody isn't like
making threats, like direct threats, it's like something to that.
Couldn't see who the stream sniper was in this one, right?
They like pull forward in the car, but it's just them in the
car. Still
basically building up this idea that there are a lot of people
who try to stream stream snipe clvicular.
>> Get this Get this little guy out here. >> Same
guy again. Same guy again.
>> All right. All right, >> dude. Now, [laughter]
uhoh.
The fact that it's the same guy every single time, is that going
to work against him or for him? This guy harasses me a lot, but
also you got a reason to actually have a grudge against this
guy now.
>> Dude, this guy has actual crackhead energy. This is
[__] crazy, dude. He just got slammed to the ground.
He gets
>> Oh,
this is [laughter] scaring us, dude. I was talking to people
about this the other day. Maybe not the other day, more like
three months ago. But I I basically just said, "You got to be
like Jack Doy, okay? Find a huge black exconvict. Okay, huge.
And just pay him to knock somebody out as deterrence.
That's literally all you should do when you're when you're rich
enough. You just you don't pay like private security. You don't
pay like actual private security. You find somebody who's like
a felon who's not really that scared to go back in and then you
get a clip like Jack Dy got of that dude getting knocked the
out and then people don't [__] with you as much.
You know what I'm saying? You know what I'm saying? Wait, why
does this look like heel mic? That looks like he It's
>> Yo yo yo, >> that's Icy. I recognize Icy. Wait,
why are there so many streamers at this thing? What the was this?
Didn't work for Jack though. People always with him. Ah, it worked
for a little bit. It worked for a little bit. Dude, that's Icy.
Yeah, I recognize Icy. It's Art Basil. No, I don't know where
this is. I don't I'm doesn't live in Florida, bro. You You would
know tourniquet. Not me. I don't [__] know.
>> Prince William and Megan Markle. Wait, not William.
Who's the guy? Who's the ginger prince?
Dude, I I don't care about British at all. I was going to do
a joke about the ginger British prince and Megan Markle. Harry.
Harry. That's the one.
>> He's a [__] idiot.
>> Get this Get this little guy out of
>> Dude. Oh boy. This guy's never getting hired again.
Hold on. Listen to this immediate interaction that happens. Okay.
Do you guys catch this? I didn't catch this the first time. Okay.
Clvicular goes, "Hey, get this little guy out of here." And the
black security guard ignores him.
>> Get this Get this little guy out of
will remember this. You do you just not listen to me? You just
not Do you just not listen to me? >> Get this Get this
little guy out of
>> You just You just I just told you to get this little
guy out of here. You just not [__] listen to me.
>> All right,
the [__] >> Dude, it looked like Clvicular
was going to do something there. And the security guard is like,
"Oh, I got to I got to take this guy out now."
this is [laughter] like an elite crackhead spawn in Florida.
Okay, this guy's got like 10 times the expected HP. This guy's
got a skull where his level's supposed to be. You don't even
know. You slam this guy to the ground, he was like neutral. He
is like an elite mob. All
You slam this guy to the ground, you expect him to be out and
done, and he just gets back up and starts sticking his tongue
out,
[laughter]
dude.
H
faces that haunt your nightmares.
What the
the Chad crackhead versus the virgin clvicia. Okay, dude. He's
Is this guy hard right now? [__] going on in this
clip? There's so many things going on in this clip.
What the is happening?
He's doing a haka. It is kind of like a haka. What is What is
the artifacting going on
There's just so many things going on all at the same time.
>> So, suffice to say, Clavicular might have some reasons
to hate this guy.
now I think I think I'm okay
with pulling this up on stream. >> I think now it is kind
of not safe for work. I don't think this is against kick toos
to watch this happen after the
Where's my sound at?
>> Oh my [__] draw.
Oh my god.
>> Oh my god.
Oh my god. >> Off the card. On the card.
>> Um, is he dead? Hopefully. Okay, that's [__]
up. Now, now hold on. Okay. Uh, one, I believe Aiden Ross announced
that this guy was not dead.
I Aiden Ross said that this guy was fine. Okay. And I don't know
anybody who's more accurate in his reporting than Aiden Ross.
>> Oh my god. >> Is he dead? >> I don't know.
>> Wait, is he dead? Oh boy. Oh boy. I like that he's so
It's so ingrained in him. He's like stressed and it's so ingrained
in him to like do this pose
to me and do this pose at the same time. He's doing it shortly
after killing somebody.
I put clvicular homicide.
Reviewing clavvicular homicide.
>> Is he dead?
>> Oh my god.
Oh my god. Off the card. He was on the card. >> Oh my god.
>> Is he dead? >> I don't know.
>> Hopefully. Oh, I thought he said oh boy. Hopefully.
Well,
well, well.
Is he dead? Hopefully. I'm guessing he saw a move. Okay. I
Oh boy.
>> Listen one more time. >> Oh my god.
Oh my god. Oh my god. >> Is he dead? >> I don't know.
>> Okay. I don't even think this statement has anything
to do with a self-defense claim. If I get attacked and slam a
dude on the ground and say hopefully it doesn't suddenly change
what happened and who instigated after the fact. So, while that
may be true in terms of
I do think there's something there where I don't think you'd
be able to argue that this statement is like more
than it is like informative. And I don't think you get this struck
from a trial. That is my impression. I'm not a lawyer, so that's
just my impression. I don't think you get that struck from like
a trial. Okay.
I think it would get played and probably the judge would say
you shouldn't consider it, but it's one of those clips where
it's like I think they're going to consider it. Even if they
get told you shouldn't read anything into it, I think they're
going to see it and go ah yeah, I don't like this. You know what
I'm saying? I don't know if it I I would agree with you. It's
possible it has nothing to do with intent. It has nothing to
do with whether or not he feared for his life. Right. I do think
there's something to be said for
like after Trump like traumatic moments, people make decisions
that don't necessarily make sense and reading malice into them
can sometimes be nonsensical as well. But that that's one of
those things that yeah, basically I think a jury would be instructed
not to read anything into that and they still would.
Now, here's the other thing. I also don't think you might not
be able to play any of this stuff in court. This might be overtly
like overly prejuditial showing this guy harassing a bunch of
streamers.
That might get ruled like out of this entirely.
Maybe not the one where he's literally harassing Clvicular though.
We'll have to see. I would like to see if you could get Pisco's
take on this or some lawyer's take. I think potentially criminal
covered it. I wouldn't be shocked if legal mindset covered it.
Now legal mind potentially criminal. I know he's like leans libertarian
on a lot of the ways he interprets legal stuff. So I I understand
that. I respect it. Okay.
But how do I put it? Legal mindset I do not respect in any way.
Okay. I respect Shawn
even if I disagree with like his, you know, philosophical leanings
in some ways. But legal mindset just doesn't even care to try
to be accurate. It's crazy. There's no way this guy presses charges.
Ah, that guy. This guy seems like he wants any attention he can
get, no matter how he gets it. I think this is the definition
of a guy who as long as an ambulance chaser goes and sees him,
he's definitely going to press charges. What do you mean?
I'm I'm almost positive that this guy would press charges. No,
we we'd for sure expect that this guy presses charges, right?
I I think for sure this guy just wants all the attention he can
get. Okay,
now let's see if we can find Hold on. 125 in here. There's like
a couple other things going on. There's this for the recap.
>> You probably just ran him over.
>> Oh my god. [gasps] Oh my card. He was on the card.
>> Do we go grab this stream and just watch from here and
just see what else gets
>> Bro, they were they were surrounding our our car. >> No
cheer.
You recorded the whole >> So when you hit that gas, you
hit the other car. You couldn't see nothing cuz he's on top.
>> Yeah, exactly. I can't I can't see [__]
>> That's when you don't take off. >> Well, that's
why. >> Well, when you're afraid Well, I don't know. I
don't know what's going on. >> I don't know how you feeling,
but
>> Oh, wow. >> Little bit more calm on that. We don't
know how this [__] >> No, you you don't know.
There's armed >> There's armed people surrounding my car.
>> Yeah. And they're armed. They all have pistols. I look
at >> [__] This is not working. Hold on. This
is not working. Kger. Well, this is true. I think I don't think
he hit the truck. I thought he hit the curb,
>> right? There's no way he hits the truck. He like hits
the curb. >> He probably just ran him over.
>> I think this truck is like saying, "No, no, no. Stop.
You just ran a guy over." I'm pretty sure when he >> run
this guy over here. >> Oh my god,
>> dude. That his buddy. >> No, I want to >> not
helping. Oh, we didn't get this clip though. This is actually
critical. Hold on. This clip right here is critical where um
he talks about GTAing some guy. This is before this is that same
night
>> Your best course of action is just getting your whip
and get the >> Yeah, I know the best course of action,
but I want to each and every one of these guys >> in GTA.
>> No, I want to Well,
>> no, in real life. [laughter]
That's a Sam Hyde moment right there
in THE RING. NO, IN REAL LIFE. AT HIS HOUSE IN CALIFORNIA IN
LA.
Not not good.
>> In GTA.
>> No, I want to Well,
>> this guy over here. >> Oh my [__]
god. >> Should I draw him with this guy?
>> Yeah. So, we'll watch this one more
>> Oh my god.
>> You probably just ran over.
>> Yeah. This this truck is too far away for that to be
what he hit. I'm pretty confident he hit the curb. Like he was
trying to turn over the curb or some
right. That's like something super hard right there.
Now hold on. Let's just
>> Oh no. This guy is still fully If we just want to slow
it down. [laughter]
>> Dude, I'm not going to lie. This guy just makes me laugh
by virtue of doing this. Like just sticking his tongue out going
insane. This is just making me
I'm sorry. It's just funny. So then he's down and then he gets
back on. He gets back on the side of the
back on the side of the here. He like kind of jumps on.
Is he getting off?
Hold on. I couldn't tell here.
I'm trying to see if he's like getting
He is turning into him a little bit. Yeah. Yeah, he's turning
into him.
Dude, now I need to see. Hold on. We got this this view right
here. Give me a second. Let's pop this view open and see if this
tells us more about where he was because he's turning into the
guy. Does it make sense for him to turn into the guy?
>> Any sense guy? >> Like what? >> He's in
there. He's in the lip.
>> Yeah, he's in the lip. We're good.
>> Oh, he just hit their car. >> Who?
Who just hit their car? >> CL just hit their car.
>> The guys. >> Oh, he is saying >> he hit
their car. Cops are running. Oh my god.
>> He hit her on purpose. No, he didn't hit him. Go over
there on the floor. What is >> What is going on? >> What's
the [__] is happening? >> Oh, the Are you guys
telling me not a single person outside of that vehicle was streaming?
Not a single person was streaming. Really? Tipster Lugie 2988.
Okay, guys. There wasn't a single person streaming from outside
the car.
>> Apparently, did they hit someone?
>> I hate y'all.
>> Okay,
now
I'm telling you.
I see.
Wait, what is this? That's a cop car. Okay, it's a cop car.
>> I think someone got >> Hold on.
>> I don't see a cyber truck here. Or is Clvicular pull
away?
>> Okay, hold on. What day was this stream?
Let me check this out. Christmas Eve IRL in Miami. Let's see
how long he stays live for.
>> But you're very pretty.
>> Come on, bro.
>> Go ahead. Get the >> You know it.
>> I want back there. >> Let's try to there. Yeah,
I know. I saw a pistol in his sweater. >> I mean, trust
me, go. >> I don't know if I want to get into a 1v8 firefight
right now. >> Yeah, you're good, bro. >> I only have
one pistol with one clip. >> Don't even like Don't even
like talk about it. Just get in your car and get right here.
>> Okay, dude. >> Yeah, you're upstairs. >> Yeah.
All right, we'll catch you later,
>> Uh, I'm not sure where we're at.
>> Yo, Marky, jump these guys right now. >> It's
not. No, it's not. It's not. >> Let me [laughter] see what
uh >> I knew there would be more here that you could just
watch this and he's going to say other crazy [__]
right? I knew, dude, you watch this bod for like these these
10, 15 minutes. Of course, he's going to say some wild [__]
right? Let me see what whip they're driving and I'm going to
get their plates.
You know what I'm saying? Even talking about it, you're like
dating them to do it.
Trust me, bro.
Your best course of action is just getting in your weapon and
get this out. >> Yeah, I know the best course of action,
but I want to keep each and every one of these guys >> in
GTA.
>> No, I want to >> Well, look, just be careful what
you say. You know, the movie is just going to try to be weird.
>> Where is you guys at?
>> live streamers in 2025 really acting like characters
from Baz Lurman's Romeo and Juliet IRL.
Yeah, this guy seems like a
Listen, this guy just bit his thumb at Clav. Okay, this guy just
bit his thumb at him. What is he supposed to do? Just walk away
without the guy? Are you serious? And be a Get the out of here.
Oh, whoops. Wrong clip. Wrong clip. Wrong clip. Wrong clip. We're
back to this guy. Do >> you want to hop in my cyber truck
and I take it? It's right here. Uh, my Cyber Truck's right at
the end there going to >> You guys good?
>> Thank you. >> Yeah, we we'll see you later, Marky.
>> All right, class. >> Let us know the moves.
>> All right. Good to meet you, too. Take care of yourself.
>> Wait, hold on. Why [clears throat] are you guys pretending
that like the Cybert truck's the same as like a Ram or something
or an F-150?
Like people do say, "I'm going to go get my Ford" or something.
I'm going to go get my truck. You could say Cybertruck if you
have a Cybert truck. It's a unique car.
I guarantee you if somebody's going to get in their Porsche,
they say, "I'm going to get in my Porsche." You know what I'm
saying?
It's like an expensive vehicle. It's not a cool vehicle, but
it's an expensive >> Let me go get some. >> Oh, no
way,
bro. Is he taking this back to the dealership after he killed
somebody with it? >> Why he got the Why he got the sticker
in the window? What the HeyO, this guy renting a Tesla and just
being like, "Look at my sick Cybert truck, guys."
This is a lease, isn't it? something. I don't think I don't think
they let you have this, right? I think if you drive this off
the lot, they take the stuff down.
They'll like put a sticker for the dealership or something, but
no, I don't believe the guy's dead. I don't believe >> See,
what do we have? What's in the
>> Just pull out and go, please.
>> let's just pull out and go, please. No.
>> What is going on here? >> When trying when trying
to look like a total psychopath at all times goes wrong. [laughter]
trying to trying to like just always be the cool psychotic uh
zero emotion guy and it just looks like you're Let's just go.
I don't want to get in a fight. No, I want to I want to wait
until I have a reason to get one of these guys.
>> Should I drive with this guy?
>> Okay. So, what I'm looking for here is to back it up
just a little bit and to see what are we dealing with here when
they walk over to the cybert truck.
So, they're sitting in the cybert truck. There's a car here.
>> He turns out this way, right? They go to the truck's
right. So, does he hit this
Does he hit He wouldn't hit this. He could hit this car as he's
turning out. >> I'm just We're trying to get a sense of
the surroundings here.
>> See what do we have? What's in the back?
>> Now, he also, by the way, is this the backup camera
or is this I don't even know what this is. Is this some like
virtual camera where it's like
it's trying to show you the surroundings? Cuz
I think with a backup camera, you do look to back up here with
a guy in front of your vehicle, right?
Like obviously. So you don't drive forward with a guy on your
on the front of your vehicle.
>> Run this guy over. >> Oh my [__]
>> Run this guy over.
>> Drive. Drive. I don't know, dude. You got to hit it
in reverse here, right? >> Oh my [__]
And he definitely hits that car that was there. I think I don't
think he hits the
>> Oh my god.
Oh my god. >> Off the card. He was on the car.
>> This dude's super helpful. He's like, "Hey, hey, whoa,
whoa." Then he points at the guy who's dying, who's got crushed
by the truck. Hey, look. Look. The guy's He's under. He's under.
He's under. He's down there. He's down there.
>> Oh my god. >> Is he dead? >> I don't know.
>> Okay, let's watch.
Now, there is no curb there. He almost certainly hit something,
right? Did he want distance from the guy before going back or
cuz he hit he I swear to God he hit something there, right? I
think it's the car. The truck wouldn't have pulled away if he
hit that truck.
>> He explains it a bit. Okay, well, we'll
>> Also,
can I just ask
why did this not make it to Twitter in full? Why would why didn't
anybody just go and clip the full section?
Why is nobody doing that? Is it because they don't want to get
DMC8 or something? Cuz like to me the whole like seven minute
section would be good to have and I've not even seen anything
outside of the stuff that's cut and I've seen stuff that's like
helpful outside of the cuts already.
So understanding the situation. >> You got to get to these
cops.
>> He is. Is he walking?
>> These people all have TO DIE. [laughter] DUDE, NOT HELPING,
CLAV. Not helping. No, not helping. Not helping.
I' I've not seen that clip either. I've never I've not seen that
clip either.
There's nobody. Okay, I'm not going to complain about it anymore.
That's crazy. That's them walking by, correct? That's the black
guy who was with him. >> These people all have to die.
>> Wait, is somebody walked by before the black guy?
>> He is. Is he walking? >> A watch.
>> No, that's not That's not the guy. That's not the guy.
That's a That's a different guy.
>> That could be the Darius looking guy right there. More
slender.
>> And the black guy comes next who's pressing with the
sign.
>> Oh no. But that's still not him. >> These people
all have to die.
>> They literally would not stop.
>> It takes all the effort in the
>> I want to run each and every one of them over. Oh, he's
on the floor.
>> Hold on. Is this the I'm looking for the soundtrack.
You need to call the police. >> It's actually going to
be it. >> I got it. >> Yeah, it is.
>> We got to get to a safe. >> What the What the
Why did this always It My YouTube music just like takes me over
to Japanese [__] all the time.
>> Get out of here. >> I'm calling 911. What the
>> Hey, don't run. Don't run.
Okay. Okay.
That's helping him a little bit that he's calling 911. >> Who's
running?
>> I need the cops. Violet, get in the car. Get in the
car.
>> Get into the car.
>> Why the [__] are the cops?
Is he Is he What is that?
Hold up. The Is this the N? Is this the emergency response we
get? >> Miami Day Sheriff's Office. What is the address
of the emergency? >> Um, I'm at this carnival. I'm I'm
not sure, but I I just was attacked by um a bunch of people.
>> It doesn't sound good when he says it that way.
I was just attacked by a bunch of people. It already sounds
like he's
I do think he could say that I was concerned. I was being harassed
by some people. Um they had weapons on them.
>> Which carnival are you at, sir? What's the address?
>> Um I am I'm at I don't know. It's Jenkinson or something.
>> Okay. When did this happen, sir? >> Uh, about
two minutes ago. Looks like there's already officers on scene.
>> Are you in the city? >> I'm sitting in. >> So,
did you want to go speak to the
>> No, because it's unsafe.
>> Are you Are you in Hay Alia, sir? >> Yes. Uh,
this is a dangerous >> Halia police. >> We need more
We need more officers. >> 911. What is the address of your
>> It's the the carnival. >> Wait, what? >> We
need more We need more officers. 911. What is the address of
your emergency?
>> It's the the carnival,
>> dude. I think is that just like bad noise cancelling?
There's like a they're in like a I don't know like a phone.
Yeah. I wonder if they're in like a like a call center kind of
thing for 911 operators or some [__] and that like
it's bad voice can or noise cancelling or some [__]
They transferred them
>> What's the address, sir?
>> Um I'm not sure. It's Jeninson's Carnival or something
like that. >> Just open Google Maps, dog. Just open Google
Maps and let your GPS tell you where you are. How difficult is
this?
>> Ripleys. Ripleys, I think it is.
>> You guys are inside the park,
>> Okay. Stay on the line for Miami. Do not hang up. >> Yeah.
Okay. It appears that we need to get a lawyer. >> It does.
It does appear
that a lawyer would be good.
>> Miami Day Sheriff's Office. What is the address of your
emergency?
>> Um, it's the >> Bro, you just keep saying correct
to people and I'm sitting here like, dude, could you just
just say yes?
>> what is it called again? not Ripley's of
>> it's you can just see all the pieces of the character
that don't feel like they make any sense after he's in this situation
that like he says it this way cuz it like sounds kind of cool
and it's sort of condescending but it's like dude this is the
last situation where this should happen it feels so
like discordant with reality right now it's so weird to watch
this happen with
is this the car that just ran that guy over correct Correct.
Did you just Did you just hack a family of five into little pieces
with a machete? Correct.
Correct. It's like, dude, can you
be cool, man?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Ripley. We're We're all >> Yeah. Yeah.
Rip. Ripley's carnival. But there's already officers on scene
now. Uh it looks like we're good. >> Okay. We can if the
officers are there, so I'll speak with them, sir. >> Okay.
Um, let's see. Hey, you guys saw that? Hey, guys.
>> You saw that,
>> bro? They were They were surrounding our our car trying
to attack us. >> We would have
took off.
>> You hit that gas.
>> You recorded the whole >> So, when you hit that
gas, you hit that other car. You couldn't see nothing cuz he's
on top. >> Yeah, exactly. I can't I can't see [__]
>> That's when you don't >> Well, that's why you
got police here. Well, when you're afraid. Well, I don't know.
I don't know what's going on. >> I don't know how you feeling,
but
>> You could have a little bit more calm on that. We don't
know how this >> No, you you don't know. There's armed
>> There's armed people surrounding my car in your car.
>> Yeah. And they're armed. They all have pistols. And
look, >> they all have pistols. So, >> if they can
prove that, you're a little bit safer. >> Well, the ones
with pistols >> open carry, but they >> It doesn't
matter. It doesn't matter. They're all unregistered guns. >> Oh,
yeah. That's a little reality shaping right there. Oh, they're
all unregistered guns. How do you know that? Now, if you had
to bet
is uh Wait, wait, wait. Is this the kind of girl kind of guy?
Is this the kind of guy who registers his weapons? Maybe not.
Maybe not. Maybe not. But how do you know that? How are you making
that up? [laughter]
His gun's unregistered. I know it for a
>> Fine. is on register. >> They show you. They flashed
it on you. That was like >> I I see the print popping through
their sweatpants when they're pressing us. I see the guys.
>> I see I I see a pistol.
>> Yes, they were they were aggressing us.
>> He's alive.
>> What is his legs? Are his legs done? >> He's moving.
>> Could have stopped talking, man. >> You got to
stop talking, man. They got to turn around.
They parking.
>> They trying to park.
They trying to >> Can I at least break his legs? Can I
at least break his legs? >> Show him. >> Whatever
video you got, >> dude. He's still on the ground.
>> He's still on the ground. Show him.
Show
on the ground,
Hey, Citrus. >> Guys, this guy's doing his best to be as
as possible right now. >> Citrus, could we get a defense
lawyer? Let me see.
My call. >> Dude, his if if this guy has a lawyer, which
it sounds like he doesn't, that lawyer would be screaming to
shut the stream off right now. Hey, stop putting evidence on
the record. Stop creating evidence.
Stop creating evidence. Stop creating evidence. Yo, >> do
you know any defense lawyers?
>> I don't. I've never been in any type of situation, so
I don't know any
>> I'm on live right now, but um I want to have like if
I don't know if you could ask like Aiden or something, but yeah.
No, this is
>> Wait, is that call waiting or did Cheeser just shut
this? Did Cheeser just like next guy?
>> Dude, you you know that guy, right? That big guy. The
big dreamer. Can that guy find me a lawyer?
>> No, no, no. Sorry. It was Citrus, wasn't it? It wasn't
Cheeser. I got it. I got it. I got it. I mixed those two up to
be fair. Citrus is
different guy. It was He was like a mod for Aiden, right? Cheeser's
like friend. Citrus was like the mod guy, I think. >> [__]
I don't I don't know that community well.
>> Citrus is an Aiden mod, I'm pretty sure.
>> Like 85%.
Hey, what's% sure?
>> my streams
>> my streams my I got banned on kick. I don't know. >> No,
they didn't ban you. Listen, I'm I'm I'm live. Don't worry. Like,
you need to just have go on IG live. You need to be live, okay?
You need to recording something. Okay,
>> dude. Dude, this guy is an actual op. I'm so sorry.
That's hilarious. Dude, I do not have content right now. I need
you on IG live. I need you on Twitch. I need YOU ON YOUTUBE.
GET ON A platform so I can watch your downfall right now. Now.
Get live right now. >> You need to be live for this. >> We're
recording. I'm recording. I'm recording. Live. >> Um, what
are they are they saying they're going to detain you? >> They're
not They haven't spoke to me yet, but I'm not going to say anything
without um a lawyer. >> Lawyer. Can you run over the police
on the scene? Can you Can you make this go away? Is there a limit
to how many people you can run over? It's a cybert truck.
It's efficient. Can you Can you just get rid of the evidence?
>> Just do not say >> Yes, of course I do. Look,
um, just hang tight. Record. Don't say anything.
>> Um, don't say don't answer questions.
Um, and and and just don't say anything, okay? I I let it play
out, but you need to be recording. Somebody needs to record you.
>> We are. Yeah, the whole thing's being recorded, but
I need Yeah, >> don't worry about that. Yes, I know what
you need and I trust me. Yes, I got you. It's the good thing
is Listen, it's Christmas and a lot of my lawyers, they don't
celebrate Christmas, so you're going to be good.
>> hold on a second. The stalker that Clvicular ran over
turned out to be an IG influencer with nearly a million followers.
He has not posted since the situation. He was also banned on
kick. Richest SE Recon X.
Bro, there there's no way this guy actually has 887,000
followers, right?
Like this is just botted engagement. I I assume like paid for
sub subs, paid for
Got to be, right?
Got to be. Okay. I I feel like we could look at the engagement
on the posts. He's famous in Florida. Okay. Maybe he's famous
in Florida, but
he's not that
The guy had to get airlifted from there, by the way. Lau the
cloud kid is no shot. Buy me a link to that. Buy me a link that
says that that guy had to get airlifted out. Get the [__]
out of here. Wait, what?
No shot. >> Too far? I don't think so. That's a bit too
far. I don't think so. I think somebody jumps on your car. Somebody
jumps on your car and like this kid had a had a a habit of harassing
him. I'll tell you all the world that I want to live in. Okay?
I want to live in a world where if you harass and stalk somebody,
they can run you over with their cyber truck and kill you. That's
the world that I want to live in. That's that's my perfect reality.
That's my version of America. Okay. So, yeah. Uh I don't care
about the law. I don't care about >> It's like It's like
too far. I don't think Hold on. Sorry. the Twitter player was
broken. While I don't agree,
I'm also sitting here, I'm like having a hard time even getting
upset cuz it's like, what did you think Asmin Gold thought? Like
that's Yeah, that's pretty much exactly what I feel like Asmin
Gold thought, right? Like I this is very predictable. It's just
exactly what what we all thought he was going to say, I believe.
Uh I don't care about the law. I don't care about like, oh well,
you're not supposed to do that or I don't care about whatever
your religious book says. I'm talking about what I think and
that's what I think. I think you should be able to run the ass
over voice. I know my voice is up today, isn't it? It's real
bad. And uh it's self-defense. Exactly. But he drove while being
coked out of his mind. You support that? Well, um if he had run
somebody else over, I wouldn't support it. But I do support it
because he ran somebody over who I think he should have run over.
It's pretty simple, actually. Damn. It's It's kind of rough that
I I just expected that to be his take. Hold on. There's another
clip here. >> Oh my god.
>> That's denied and unknown to be >> Dude, the Dexter
music still works for him. He doesn't want to say anything. Doesn't
want to say anything. >> Is he dead? >> I don't know.
>> Absolutely beautiful.
Truly beautiful.
Amazing. I love it. Is the car okay? It's a cyber truck. >> Okay.
I I can't say so hard. Like I feel like my take on this is basically
something like
do think it's possible he has a valid selfdefense claim here.
But I don't think it's something where you're just like based
cuz this guy was annoying. I don't know if you could quite do
that.
I feel less sympathy cuz the guy was annoying. I don't feel no
sympathy. I don't know.
It's like if Clvicular had like actually thrown a punch at this
guy, I don't think I'd be that upset, but the car thing you just
can't control. Like if you if you roll over this guy's brain
and just squish his head, right? You just roll over his head
as you're like running him over and you kill him. Like that's
not proportionate even to the harassment obviously. I don't know.
I don't know if you can like escalate to, oh, this guy should
be killed. Like I don't like Asmold's straight up saying this
guy should be killed. I'm like, well,
like, >> the car is fine. You know what? That's a good
point. I think that this kid should have to pay Clav for any
damage to the car, stalking and harassing him. So, whenever I
ask, here's a question, right? If a girl was in a car and a stalker
guy gets on her hood and prevents her from leaving her driveway
or leaving where she's at.
Ah, that doesn't work here. Here's the
What I'm taking into account is that I went through more than
the clips. I went and looked at where he was parked, how he was
parked, and how he could have moved out of that situation,
right?
And if Asmin Gold, if I go watch Asmin Gold's video and he doesn't
go and do that, and then he starts making comparisons to like,
well, this guy was being blocked in by dudes with guns. That's
not what happened, man. He could have backed up. He could have
thrown that [__] in reverse and backed out of there.
I don't think forward was the only way. I don't think turning
into that guy was the only way. Yeah. So, I think you have some
kind of duty to retreat here, right? >> Did we get his
ID?
>> Can you can you give me your ID?
>> Were you guys filming a video or something and this
guy was part of your
of this person >> at all. >> I need um camera down.
>> We're conducting investigation right >> I know
you're con this is for this is for our >> Is that a legal
request? You can record all you want.
Okay. Keep it. Sure.
Let me have your ID everybody in the >> That guy,
this cop not happy with these dudes. That guy must be up. Don't
Tesla trucks have a forward reverse or not have a forward reverse?
It just uses AI to choose which one and you press the
Wait, there's no shot.
What?
No, it has to have a manual reverse. Maybe it's difficult to
figure out if you're putting it in reverse or not. Or maybe maybe
to manually put it in reverse. That's like difficult. But it
would have a manual reverse thing
cuz obviously if one of your camera gets disabled cameras gets
disabled somehow or broken. There's no way they just like Oh
yeah, you can't back up.
I would believe that you have to like do something. Yeah. On
the touchcreen to reverse. I would believe that. And it's like
inconvenient or something.
Maybe that makes a difference. >> No. No. Don't lose.
>> Do I have to? >> Yes. You have to give ID. Yes.
>> You're in the car. You're involved. Everybody has a
good idea. >> See, that's the whole thing.
>> Hold on. Asmin Gold reacts to his favorite video. A
clvicular X Nick Fuentes edit. This gives me hope for America.
It goes so hard. From the Clipper
Zerkapill. From from the Clipper Zerkapill.
We bring you a cinematic
>> Oh, I didn't see that one. was all the times he went
and [__] with him. >> All the times he was
annoying.
>> Sit down and shut.
>> That's what a man has to say.
dude. Asminold is going to single-handedly the generational run.
This is the worst thing I've ever seen. He's making Nick look
so gay.
dude. This is rough.
This is really, really rough. Now, I know the context on these
clips, too. None of these clips make any sense. This is Oh, can
you make can you make a Nick Fentes and clvicular?
Because if you can, this is it. Somehow they took a bunch of
awesome Nick Fentes clips and turned it into
I don't I don't know how they did it. I don't know how they did
it. >> It's time to handle this.
>> Be honest, bro. Like, this is my favorite video, bro.
Yesterday I saw that. That [__] was so funny, man.
Oh my
Oh no.
This is like one of those things where I start to get schizophrenic
and I think that like all of these influencers actually run with
like an agency who runs analytics who's like some some analytics
thing they set up and they figure out what people are watching
and all of them are like yeah we're like you got to double down
on watching Fentes Fente has big numbers right now. And so they
hand this clip off to Asmin Gold and he goes and he laughs and
he says it's so awesome and he loves this his favorite video.
And if he knew anything going on in the video, he just like wouldn't
find it funny. Why? Right.
And I just feel like it's just like he's just he's somebody who's
trying to like use he's like oh he's somehow
or like um focus grouped but in like a
white alternate alternative political view kind of way. Like
this is this is like the Disney of white nationalism is Asmin
Gold.
You guys feel that? Do you see what I'm talking about? You see
what I'm like trying to put in your mind here? It's like the
Disney of white nationalism.
It's actually dog.
It's like depressing to watch. And I usually think Asmin Gold's
like funny or like I understand where Asmin Gold's coming from.
Why the do you think Asmin Gold does any research on anything
ever? I don't think he does. I feel like he got handed this clip
and was just like this is so awesome.
It's rough. This is rough to watch.
And this audio is so unnecessarily bad. It has to be, man. [laughter]
So bad. That guy, that was hilarious. I'm so confused. Uh I I
don't understand this. I'll run you over because I don't know
what you're willing to do for my property. Absolutely, man. Yes.
This gives me hope for America. It goes so hard. It does. And
that's not a good quote. That's That's him reading a chat. He
says it does, but like that's a bad quote. That's a disingenuous
quote right >> This is what I've been waiting. I've been
waiting on this for a long time. I have been. I'm so happy for
this. Damn. Yeah, bro. Like, >> damn. At Asmin Gold salute.
Asmin Gold just likes stuff. If he's going to cover it on stream,
by the way, he just lets his algorithm guide him and then he
just comments on it on stream. Lady, I know this Permabola account
that posted it,
right? Wait, hold on. Where's the permabula? Oh, this is the
Sorry, this one. Permabula. I know that. I know that account
from something. >> That was hilarious. I'm so confused.
Uh I I don't understand. >> Probably a racist account.
My lady PFP.
Odds are.
Okay.
Sorry. We're still going on. I don't even think we finished all
of Clav's vaude yet. >> Give me a second.
>> Like three minutes left on this. Two minutes left on
this. >> All right. Let me see. I um I have my my license
plate down here. I forgot to switch on. There's a dealer plate
on there right now, but
uh let me see.
>> I believe it's on the floor. Yeah, I got it right here.
This is my actual license >> Hey, do me a favor. >> I
don't I don't know what's going on with why he got this truck.
I wouldn't be totally shocked if he was just taking this truck
around because somebody said it would be cool if he did it. Like,
hey, you just want a cool guy riding around in a cyber truck?
I'm guessing I'm guessing there are people in Miami.
If it's not like straight up somebody who's related to Tesla,
I'm guessing they're like dealership owners in Miami who like
to form relationships with these people.
>> Did you hear that?
Let me turn it up.
>> He might be on something. >> He might be on something.
Dude, that's not good for him. I guarantee you he is on a lot
of things. Some of them might be disallowed like for driving
and I don't know. Somebody said he's coked up. I have no idea
if he's coked up, but like he might be on amphetamines at a high
enough level that they consider
driving under the influence, right? Like he might be I have no
idea what this guy's on. This guy's one of those He says he uses
Yeah. So
he's one of those guys who's like a biohacker, right? Isn't he
a known user unironically?
Possibly. Yeah. takes looks max. Okay. Well,
he he said he stayed up stayed up for three days in a row in
crystal. Maybe he's just trolling though. No, he seems like somebody
who would do like you can do meth as a part of a prescription.
Like like straight up methamphetamine
is something you can take as a prescription. Like if you have
really crippling ADHD, they'll give it to you.
If you're like resistant to other forms of ADHD treatment, I
think they'll give you actual.
>> There's a script in the center console. There was What
was it? >> I think I passed it here. >> This is my
Let me see. >> When he goes to grab this,
>> see if I scan if I can see it again here. No, I don't
think you can see anything on this.
Let me have your ID, too.
>> When did this show up? I can see it here. There we go.
>> Yeah. Hard to catch anything off of
>> Let me see. >> I don't know. >> I um I have
my my license plate down here. I forgot to switch on. There's
a dealer plate on there right now. But
>> what's up, Safia? How's it going?
>> 24 months.
>> You ain't seen you moving right now. No, you see how
loud the other cop was detected heard
>> to run his
>> Okay. All right. All right. >> Your brother safe.
>> So, they're saying that
he's a good guy. The one on the ground was the bad guy. He just
did what he had to do. At least your brother's safe. >> That's
my friend right there. >> Oh, man. Come on, bro. He He
the good >> He is >> the on the ground. The bad guy.
He did what he was supposed to. Run his
>> Okay. All right. >> Okay. Hey, brother safe.
>> Damn, your big ass should have came out and helped,
>> bro. I wasn't. >> This is This is the fat guy
who's watching with or walking with Clvicular earlier in the
previous clips. MAN, YOUR BIG ASS SHOULD HAVE BEEN OUT HERE.
I HAD LEFT. And >> you know what the trick is? I don't
know him, right? But when he was coming in, I was joking saying,
"Hey, bro, put me on the blog." >> I see him coming out.
>> And it was some guys. It was some guys >> No.
Yeah. I don't think I saw that. I was with him. or what was transpired.
But you can tell it wasn't that nice. >> It wasn't that
nice. I came over here. >> That's what I told him. That's
what I told him. >> You better walk around my [__]
I walked up to his car and I left. >> I think he is. >> Okay.
All right. All right. All right. Okay. Well,
now
one second.
One more clip, but I don't know if this is going to be relevant.
We might have already watched this. Uh, this is Aiden Ross's
talking about whether or not Clav should have been banned. Bro,
that was crazy. Oh wow. They four for him.
>> Kick kick shouldn't do that, bro. Kick should not do
like that. Kick is kind of a for that in my opinion. Like I get
it. They got to protect the platform, but like that's that could
[__] him really >> Yeah. No, it's all off camera.
>> Yeah. No, that's that's bad. They should not they should
not do that in my opinion. They should at least private it to
where like you can't come on to the stream, but they should not
404 for that. That's really stupid because god forbid something
happens and they don't have it on camera.
Somebody next to somebody near Clab should tell him to go to
record. Mark, if you're actually on the scene, you should tell
Clab to start recording or
>> I don't think he's banned. They just took his channel
or his live down. >> That's really stupid though, bro.
Really
>> Is he still banned? Let's see.
Hick. Hick.com/clavvicicular.
He gone.
Nope. He gone. He gone. He gone. He gone.
He ain't there. Unlucky, man. Unlucky.
Okay, where are we going from here?
But I did get linked.
I think I got told, "Hey, the first 15 minutes of the Turkey
tom thing is pretty funny." You guys want to check this out real
quick? Little little clavvicular history lesson real quick. Real
quick in and out. Clvicular history lesson.
Take a look. >> Moging. Looks maxing. These are all >> Oh,
hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Tom >> Moging. Looks maxing.
These are all terms we take for granted as part of popular internet
zoomer lexicon. But not too long ago, these terms were reserved
for a few niche boards on websites that the general public had
no knowledge of. And these ideas have only become more popular
with the rise of a new figure. Clavvicular, a 19-year-old.
>> Not true. All of these terms became way more popular
before Clap took off at
>> I'm sorry. Mewing and mogging. Come on. >> Streamer
whose entire philosophy rests on the idea that looks matter.
And if you're not using his methods, you're going to be left
behind. Clav is definitely an interesting guy and his popularity
is more reflective of the culture that created him rather than
his own personal successes or shortcomings. At the same time,
he probably needs some serious help. And while on one hand, I
do feel bad for him and on another he's pretty funny, how much
sympathy can be extended to someone who tells his fans that steroids
and are the way to ascend. This is the story of Clav, the world's
most popular looks maxer. The rise of clavvicular. We're not
going to watch the whole thing. We might do 10 15 minutes. Okay.
>> Clvicular was born in December of 2005 to a wealthy
family in the northeastern
seen. Interesting title. Interesting
>> United States. Instead of public school, he attended
an all boys private high school, which just goes to show that
his upbringing already set him apart from the average person.
But even among his peers, his interests would diverge completely
from the typical student. While most kids were studying and playing
Call of Duty, Clav was getting into looks maxing. As its name
suggests, looks maxing is the idea of improving your looks. The
origins of this term are somewhat difficult to place, but today
the term is most commonly attributed to looksax.org.
Clav began browsing the site while in high school, supposedly
coming to a personal epiphany. Looks matter above all else. If
you don't have friends, it's because you're not good-looking.
Want to succeed in relationships? You need to be good-looking.
You want a dream job? Well, you also need to be good-looking
for that. >> Let's go. Let's go.
>> Some basic methods for looks maxing are pretty typical.
Go to the gym. Eat a balanced diet. Get some sunlight so you
don't look like you just rolled out of a coffin. But these are
all things that people have been doing anyway. Your dad probably
told you to go to the gym instead of playing Halo all night.
Or maybe that was just me. But some looks maxers are in favor
of using more drastic methods. Clav claims that he was just 14
years old when he ordered testosterone off the internet for the
first time. Obviously, testosterone is a naturally occurring
hormone in all of us, but Clav was taking it to accelerate his
progress in the gym. Or as he puts it, I started roids about
2 weeks after I started lifting. Why? Because natty gains are
slow and gay. >> What's up? I just want to
>> I This might be true, right? I think
I think I've talked about like there's a couple people I know
who are just like weirdo like I know a guy who's kind of like
this kind of like this in some ways. Okay. I think there are
basically
there are things you can do in terms of
like hormone replacement
you basically aren't going to be doing harm to your endocrine
system. It's just a matter of getting like your blood tested
and and getting it like blocked in correctly. I would just never
trust myself to do that, right? Like I do think there are ways
you can like figure this out if you really want to. It's not
going now. Why would you even suggest that? That's crazy. So
I think most So a lot of he's probably his endocrine system cuz
he's taken like Tren and but I do think most people I think you're
capable of doing this [__] I just I I don't know
if I'd order
bathtub hormones to do my own HRT at home. I just think that's
probably a little crazy. give a uh comprehensive overview of
SARMs or selective androgen receptor modules, what I think about
them, my experience with them, and if you should take them. Now,
SARMMs are not as researched as anabolic steroids,
so we don't currently know the long-term side effects. So, that
risk is already present. [snorts] To make things simple, SARMs
are essentially gourmet steroids. They're marketed as having
less side effects than the stuff bodybuilders used to put up
their butts. But at the same time, they do suppress natural testosterone
production, which can have some pretty noticeable side effects
on your body. If you've ever seen a male bodybuilder develop
fleshy man, it's because they took steroids for some period of
time and it messed up their
>> That's [__] up. >> But most bodybuilders
are taking these performance enhancers after puberty has ended.
Clav was starting them before he was even halfway through his
natural development as a man. Based on his video, he's well aware
of the risks, but it's a trade-off he was comfortable with because
he claims to have gained 55 lbs of muscle in 12 weeks. It's also
worth noting that this video is partially his own personal experiences,
but it's also a promotion of these substances to anyone who stumbled
across it. He recommends what to take if you're fat and want
to lose weight. What to take if >> Why does he speak so
slow? It's a weird cadence, too. I don't think he talks like
that anymore. I think that's how some people just talk, man.
He's obviously like very to join like the looks maxing community.
I assume you have to be, right? I'm guessing he was
doing this from a young age. He's probably not super socially
adept, right?
He's probably doing a lot of this instead of actually socializing.
I don't know. You mean Turkey Tom? No, I mean I mean this guy.
I think BB Poison's talking about this guy, not Tom. or if he's
talking about Tom, I have no idea why why you're saying that.
>> you're skinny and want to gain muscle and how to do
it most effectively. >> Now, there is a bit of an increased
libido. Like, you might catch yourself
uh you know, going on Tinder at 12:00 a.m. You know, I've there's
been times when I was on SARMs where I'd be on Tinder at 12:00
p.m. You know, swiping on these >> Tinder at 12:00 p.m.
and then 12 a.m. >> ugly ass, you know. Let's not get into
that. But um these videos are from 2022 and were seemingly recorded
on the same day. During the rest of that year and 2023, there
doesn't seem to be any significant online activity from him.
But that doesn't mean he was leaving internet life behind. You've
probably heard at least one term like mogging, mewing, beta,
alpha, and sigma males, red, blue, and black pills, virgin, Stacy,
and Chad, among many others. What you probably don't know is
that like pretty much everything online nowadays, these terms
originated in mostly right-wing forums and
>> Okay, I thought he was going to say they all originated
at looksmax.org. I'm like, dude, >> image boards from over
a decade ago. Before LooksMax was popular, it had three spiritual
predecessors.
an anti- pickup artist forum which mass shooter Elliot Roger
was active in,
which was later renamed Red Pill Talk and was once directly addressed
by the inventor of mewing himself, Dr. Mike MW. >> The
first response came from inel
>> I do love some of the names you've got >> And
lookism.net, the latest and least relevant out of all of these.
Wait, wouldn't I feel like the bodybuilding.org forum would be
would that not be like a predecessor to all these things?
Isn't that where this came from origin or BB is it
isnet or.org? I I feel like body the bodybuilding forums were
like legendary. >> Many similar sites went the way of the
dodo as their users found a more reliable place with faster servers
that could host their discussions, Reddit. But in 2017, social
media companies led a massive crackdown on anything that was
deemed online extremism. Among the many casualties was the shutdown
of the subreddit r/insel.
On one hand, you had people saying that these communities were
dangerous and needed to be purged from the web. But the opposing
argument apart from being in favor of freedom of speech generally
also >> is that if these people aren't exposed to regular
people, they'll just become insular and in a bubble and they'll
all like continue on their way. They'll never ever come back
to the light. Also had a foreoding warning. The idea that banning
these communities from the general internet would cause a pressure
cooker effect where the people using them would just gather on
more extreme platforms. And indeed they did. The shutdown of
r/inscels,
>> dude. Dude, I love that >> internet would cause
a >> The thing they're doing is these are just all gamers.
This is like regular Twitch streamers and not >> pressure
cooker effect where the people using them would just gather on
more extreme platforms. And indeed, they did. The shutdown of
r/Incels
instantly led to the creation of four different websites. Incelss.is,
which is a general forum for incels. NES.net net created for
people who are not in employment, education, or training. Sanctioned
Death, a site that allegedly provides instructions on how to
uh you know, >> and finally, looksmmax.org.
It's during 2024 that most of Clav's posts on this forum take
place. One of the earliest posts I found is him replying to someone
named Big Black Oily Booty, who claimed
>> to be 15 years old. Clav replied to him saying, "Log
out of this site and play with your friends. Don't ruin your
mental development with autism. Unfortunately, this is advice
that he himself did not take. One month or so after his 18th
birthday, he made a post saying he had already gone on four steroid
cycles with doses as high as 550 milligrams of testosterone weekly.
For reference, the testosterone they give middle-aged men to
get their tea levels healthy. Bro, re really
really Tom, you gota do you gotta do like this >> tops
out at 200. In the same post, he also notes that taking substances
in the past had seriously affected his liver health, but this
didn't seem to be a major concern for him. By age 16, he was
spending $700 per steroid cycle. But somewhat ironically, his
drug use ranked pretty low in terms of bizarre methods he was
using to supposedly improve his looks. While Looks Maxers believe
that your body is an important part of improving your looks,
equally important is your face. Having a strong jawline, high
cheekbones, and hunter eyes are heralded as the pinnacles of
looks maxing. Everyone talks about getting hunter eyes, and everyone
talks about a positive canal tilt, but no one tells the truth.
Here's the full guide on how to actually get hunter eyes. According
to Clav, one of the meth truth, here's the full guide on how
to actually get hunter eyes. >> I'm sorry. It's like I
can sense that this guy was not Listen, God didn't want you to
be a Chad. God didn't want you to be a gigachad. Okay? God gave
you the genetics you got. All right? And and you can't fool us.
Okay? You can't fool me. Can't fool us. According to Clab, one
of the methods he used was called thumb pulling, which entailed
pulling the roof of his mouth outwards to widen his jaw. He also
chewed gum, which supposedly helped his jawline as well. All
of these are obviously unconventional, but the strangest method
is bone smashing. The idea that by lightly hitting your face
with a hammer or other object, you can create micro fractures
that when healed, supposedly enlarge or strengthen the bones
underneath. I know it hurts, but that means it's working. That's
the only indication you have.
>> Listen,
I if maybe it does. Maybe it works. Maybe it actually works,
but you're literally hitting yourself in the face with a baseball
on stream.
I'm sorry. >> Pass the pain. Look at me. >> While
he acknowledges that the effects of bone smashing are most likely
not permanent, he still claims that it swells up his face and
makes him look more defined. Although, I'm not sure I >> Wait,
PSL. Okay, the PSL thing is like your facial score or whatever.
A 0.25 PSL boost.
I use it for the effect of temporarily swelling my bones for
a 30 minute plus 0.25 PSL boost. Bill claims that it swells up
his face and makes him look more defined. Although, I'm not sure
I see much of a difference in this before and after other than
lighting. Now, one question you're probably asking after seeing
all of this is why. Clav was already a reasonably attractive
person before any of this, and it was all due to genetics. Were
the steroids, strange techniques, and thousands of dollars spent
really worth it? I would argue no, especially since two major
things he was seemingly ignoring were his mental well-being and
his general social skills. In one post, he states that he dreads
going to get haircuts. >> Hey, pig. >> Oh, hold on.
>> Ruben donated $3. Bro should have named himself Mandibular
>> cuz as he puts it, I'd rather look homeless than have
to talk to someone for 30 minutes straight. God, I want a rope
max. He even went as far as making an entire thread about
>> dude. Okay, this is kind of this is kind of hilarious.
Here's how I say 50 words or less per day [laughter] >> is
crippling social anxiety. I dread talking to people in real life,
even if it's for 30 seconds. I'd do anything to avoid those awkward,
meaningless exchanges. Here's how I say 50 words or less per
day. I wake up 30 minutes earlier than I have to so I don't have
to see my parents in the morning. I get >> private huff.
Thank you for the gifted >> Up at 6:00 a.m. for school,
even though I don't start for like 2 hours after that. I just
sit in my car and wait for it to start. Don't walk into class
first or last. Both of which draw attention, which I don't want.
I just walk in the middle of the pack so no one notices. Sit
in the middle of the room. Sitting in the back may cause the
teacher to cold call you to try to catch you not paying attention.
Sitting in the middle has allowed me to never get called on for
a question the entire year. Keep eye contact with the teacher
and divert your attention whenever she looks at you to another
person. Also, never use your phone when you're not supposed to.
She will go out of her way to embarrass you. Don't follow anyone
on Instagram. This will make it awkward to walk by them. Am I
supposed to greet this person now? I don't want to talk to you.
Don't try to make small talk. Then it is custom to greet people
the next day. >> Ignore everyone. >> I really am
just a nice guy. I swear. >> Thank you so much for the
three doom friends. Appreciate it, buddy. >> Never participate
in class discussions. >> Start counting your words. You
shouldn't be saying more than 50 to 100 words per day. I have
gone entire days without speaking before this. >> Can we
find Can we find Cleman's account on this website? Cuz he decided
to take this and make it his entire personality for streaming
and that's [__] up. What's up, Lab? How's it going?
>> This is This is where I go when I need to fall asleep.
I just joined this VC.
>> Oh, cool. We're watching all the Clvicular stuff. You
caught up on any of that, Mico? Thank you for the gifted sub.
Let's go.
>> Um, I am not very caught up, but I know who Cleavvicular
is.
>> Was watching Turkey Tom go over all of his looks.org
posts.
He's explained how he says less than 50 words per day. >> Yeah,
it's good times.
>> Pay in class discussions. >> Start counting your
words. You shouldn't be saying more than 50 to 100 words per
day. I have gone entire days without speaking before. This should
be your goal. When walking into a room, don't make eye contact
with anyone. >> If I need to, just give them a nod and
walk the other way. During lunch, I always sit in the library
and fast so that I don't have to go through the shame of eating
lunch alone. This will cause social stigma. Don't be this kid.
Just go somewhere else. When I get home, I try to go straight
to my room without seeing my parents. I always greet my dog,
though, because I love her. This is the only female I will ever
feel a connection to.
>> Fox's dog.
>> Sorry, I had to move to the page in the board. greatly
for my dog because she gets so happy when I come home from school.
When I go to have my pre-workout meal, I eat it at an obscure
time to avoid overlapping dinner with the rest of my family who
are always home. At the gym, I always wear a hoodie and sweatpants.
Dark colors to be unapproachable. This is ideal. Never wear deodorant
to the gym. No one asks you to work in ever if you smell really
bad. Only do this at the gym, not anywhere else, because it draws
attention. When I get home, I go straight to my room to come
on looksmax.org or incelss.is
for the rest of the night. Sometimes I watch a movie. I recommend
you try to go an entire day doing your normal regime without
talking. Whenever I talk, I give away my blue pill and reveal
my mental issues. I used to have a therapist but stopped going
because of how dreadful it is. They constantly try to blue pill
you and warp your sense of reality. On one hand, I think some
of this post
What did he read? He wrote this when he was what, 18.
Very cool. >> Isn't he only like 19 now?
>> Yeah. Well, this is April 4th, 2024.
>> You see him run that guy over?
>> Yeah, I did. Is the guy alive >> over random people?
Uh yeah, I think he's alive, but also I somebody said they airlifted
him out. I've not seen any evidence of that, but definitely when
they look at him like 10 minutes after he's run over, he's still
just laying on the ground motionless.
So,
>> hello. Thoughts on running over people? You shouldn't.
That's my thoughts.
>> Unless they're Black Lives Matter protesters, you know,
getting in the way of you going to work. >> Black Lives
Matter. Unless you support Black Lives Matter. Very okay. Yeah,
I get it. I I I get it. >> Post is exaggerated to get attention
from other people on the forum. One user would even reply simply
stating, "This is what people on this website do." And then they
complain they get no attention from women. At the same time,
social anxiety might be some
Okay, hold on. Do we hit another hour?
I mean, we're close. Yeah, we're definitely like there for another
hour.
Yeah, we got another hour. I'll add it right now.
>> Okay. Something that affects him. In one post, he claims
that in real life, he's generally perceived as a pretty normal
guy. He says he has no problem speaking to girls or giving class
presentations, but whenever he posts on the forum, people immediately
sense his social awkwardness. It almost seems like he cares more
about users on this website liking him than people in his real
life. On that same note, one strange pattern I noticed with his
posts are the complete contradictions. For example, he ends this
one post with this sentence. You guys who bang and off multiple
times a week disgust me. Okay, fair enough, I guess. In the same
post, he says that he pumps and dumps girls bi-weekly, which
I assume means he was having casual hookups with women every
other week. But in another post, just two days after, he
>> What?
Didn't catch that. What did you say, Lav? I didn't hear you.
>> I literally didn't say a thing. >> You're gaslighting
me. Okay, cool. He says, "I wind up.
>> You're my You're my new Dan. You show up and then you're
like, I'm I'm EP. I just took my medicine. I'm Eie. I can't I
can't even." >> Good one. >> Good one. Gooning once
every couple of days. Obviously, these posts are in complete
conflict with each other. On one hand, he hates people who have
and goon. On the other, he also does both of these things. Clab
was trying his best to make it out of the hood. At this point
in his life, while he was attending high school and college,
his academic pursuit seemed far less interesting to him than
what was happening online, which to be honest is one thing I
definitely relate to him on. He had already started a Tik Tok
account to show his transformations to the world and generate
a little bit of conversation online about it. But he was still
trying to create some separation between his real life and what
was happening online. At one point, he shared his list of things
to never talk about with normies. This includes seed oils and
food dyes, asking for food to be cooked in grass-fed butter,
JFK assassination, tap water filled with estrogen, COVID vaccines,
Michelle Obama's gender, Volkswagen Tiguan, Hollywood,
women's right to vote, how epic05 Tacomaomas are, saying the
phrase based and redpilled, Holocaust Death Count, Crime Statistics,
Kanye West, weightlifting and macros, car modding, the word kek,
race relations, and finally Queen Cleopatra's race. Now, you
may have some questions.
>> No, you should always correct that last one. She was
Greek. >> Always correct that last one. Everything else
maybe don't talk about. That last one needs to be discussed >> about
many of these things. But if you're wondering about the Volkswagen
Tiguan specifically, he says, "I took a true Stacy on a date
and ranted about how much I hate the Volkswagen Tiguan, which
apparently dried her out. Don't recommend talking about that."
But as time passed, the line between his online activity and
his normal life began to blur. In one post, he talks about how
some girl he was talking to looked up his Tik Tok handle and
from there found his account on LooksMax. Along with the post
where he talked about his on the forum, Clav struggles with online
dating are pretty well documented. He can be seen asking for
help on what kind of pictures to put on his profile to get better
matches while also complaining about how incapable he is of holding
any kind of conversation with the women he does end up matching
with. This would be a persistent issue for him to the point where
he made a YouTube video about it. My biggest point of >> Okay,
we're done after the YouTube video, guys. We're going on to >> recently
has been online dating. I don't know where I'm going wrong, which
is why it's so frustrating. I don't know what I'm saying. I don't
know what I'm supposed to say. And I I there's just no real way
to be logical in when you're texting these girls. There's no
feedback system. They'll just stop texting you out of nowhere.
Like you'll just be texting a girl, having a normal
just no reply. Casper the ghost. >> Has he tried giving
them a a five question like post interaction survey?
>> Has he? Yeah, he should do that. >> you should
try that >> at that point. It's not like, okay, well, this
is what I It's not like a G where you could go and do some like
game film after the fact and say, oh, I shouldn't have said that.
Maybe I pushed it over the line. Just be a perfectly normal conversation.
Well, I could I could be What did I do? How about that? How about
you do me the courtesy of after all these conversations and text
messages that I don't even want to you think I want to talk about
your hobbies? I want to get in your pants, godamn it. And I want
to convince you that I'm not trying to you, which is why I'm
having the conversation. And to be honest, I think some of this
experience is probably relatable to a lot of guys. What hopefully
isn't relatable is that in some of his other posts, his conclusion
was basically to give up on dating altogether. This really comes
to a head with one thread simply titled
Mog with girls. I'd rather goon 247
damn than have to cope and jester on dating apps or cold approach
a dumb girl. Conversing with low IQ primitive women is insanely
difficult for me and I can't fake the interaction for over 5
minutes. Doesn't feel as good as my hand death gripping my on
my triple monitor setup. Girls give you a take your money. Plus,
when I off, I can sit on my hand till it's numb and pretend a
blonde Stacy is me. How poetic. >> God, I'm gooning.
>> It's probably worth noting here that taking steroids
can also screw up your drive with some drugs causing it to go
through the roof, while others will cause it to plummet to the
point where are basically impossible. By this point, it's clear
that his looks maxing had very little to do with being successful
with women, and instead it had warped into some strange mixture
of vanity and personal obsession, and his methods would once
again become increasingly bizarre. He began taking an interest
in plastic surgery. Some posts detail him dropping some money
on small things like cyst removals, while others had him asking
other forum users how he could perform surgery on himself. And
depending on what you qualify as plastic surgery, he's actually
done it on himself multiple times. Well, I can't show it on YouTube.
>> Dude, does Tom get into like him injecting the face
of his girlfriend? Cuz that was kind of weird. I don't see it
here, but >> there's multiple videos of him injecting himself
with something called lemon bottle, which is a controversial
substance that supposedly dissolves fat in your body. In time,
this became a regular part of his regimen along with another
method using PDIO threads. From what I can tell, PDIO threads
are basically the temporary tattoo equivalent of facelifts. Small
dissolvable strings that go under your skin and stimulate collagen
production while making your face look tighter. I can't speak
as to how risky or effective they are, but I also don't think
it's good to do it as much as Clab does. >> We're probably
going to do four more to get maximum
hunter eyes. And these methods also don't just stop at improving
his face card. He claims to have injected lemon bottle into the
base of his shaft as well as sticking PDO threads into it. I
did eight threads in total today. I only went
>> what? Oh my god,
>> this this sentence is crazy.
I did eight in total. I only went in about quarter inch to the
on the forearm.
>> Oh my god.
[laughter] went about a fourth inch in to mog the on the forum.
I don't think anyone has ever written something like that before
in all of human history. So, I guess I have to give him points
for being original. Even other people on the site told him this
was a horrible idea, as basically every reply is calling him
stupid or mourning the loss of his penile function. Since we're
on the topic, he also does dickups, which are exactly what they
sound like. You awaken the ancient one and you flex it up as
hard as possible for four sets of 12. And to progress the exercise,
you can add a hand towel on top of it. According to Clab, he
was up to four hand towels and had gained half an inch of girth.
Of course, the looks maxing journey never ends. And even this
stuff is really >> it's start it is starting to get into
like are are we sure he wasn't just like mocking these people
the whole time with the character?
>> Just the tip of the iceber. I guess he literally does
the surgery stuff like the threads or whatever to his face on
stream. So it's like I it's a bit but it's like also you're leaning
into the bit. You're actually doing the thing. >> Clav
made several posts about wanting to get some more serious plastic
surgeries. He explored getting an oler plasty which alters the
appearance of your nostrils, a rhinoplasty which changes the
bridge of your nose, and of course Botox insertions. As for Botox,
he didn't want to get it done by the doctor. Instead, he was
interested in doing it himself, asking members of the forum where
he could get it online. But eventually, he went and had it done
by a professional, which is why his face now has kind of a stiff,
emotionless appearance. It's at this point that we begin to see
the line being crossed as Clav goes from exclusively affecting
himself with his antics to potentially affecting other people
in a variety of ways. One of his biggest threads from this era
features him taking pride in banging a girl who is in a relationship.
What's funnier, or more strange about it, depending on how you
look at it, is that he recorded audio of her crying about it
afterwards to own her. Besides this, he frequently expressed
his pride about purposely tricking people on TikTok into doing
fake looks maxing techniques. This would be taken to the next
level when after enrolling in college, Clav was outright planning
to start doing boat. >> So, like that's definitely what
the thing was then, right? >> Talks injections for other
students to make a quick buck. funnily enough, before he expressed
his intention to do this, he was concerned about being kicked
out if the college ever found his social media accounts, only
to turn around and make plans to run a plastic surgery operation
out of his dorm. He also made some other thread announcing that
he won't be paying taxes. I guess that one is is kind of based.
I can't lie. Whether true or not, it seems like his concern about
being kicked out of college is performative. If anything, it
seemed he was looking forward to it as it would give him an excuse
to completely give up on trying to live a normal life so that
he can go allin on being an online personality as he was already
trying to do at this point through his Tik Tok and YouTube. Clim
not being invited out by anyone. And even when he did get with
a woman, he had to be on multiple drugs to be able to perform
due to his severe erectile dysfunction because of course he had
ED. He was also posting Tik Toks during this time period with
captions like 99% of people are utterly repulsive to even look
at. They should be grateful when I'm in their presence. I'll
make a brief detour here to cover one of the stranger oddities
in Clav's story. I lean toward it not being true, but given that
he later walked back and edited the thread to erase it, I honestly
can't be sure. Fortunately for us, the original thread was maintained
via a quote in one of the replies. And although the overall details
aren't really important, the story basically goes that a girl
he liked started dating a Chad. So his response was to wait for
her outside her house and literally flash her naked in a trench
coat. The girl was start >> uh that's not funny. You shouldn't
do that. Don't do that. That's weird and creepy and not funny.
hurdled and dropped her phone as she ran away, which Clav proceeded
to pick up, post a picture of his balls to her Snapchat, and
then Venmo himself $250.
Again, this is what Clav is claiming in the post. It could easily
be a tall tale, but and then everybody claps. >> In any
case, that's simultaneously hilarious and horrifying. At this
point, Clav had already soured so much on the idea of college
that he began to make threads recommending that instead of spending
$250,000
on education, it's better to take that money and spend it all
on plastic surgeries to be an influencer, which is basically
a projection of his own aspirations, as he was already saving
for a $25,000 surgery. Anyway, another traumatic event that may
have contributed to his hatred for education is the
>> I'll let him tell it.
>> Oh, yeah. >> Listen, I This is just all funny
stuff. So, I don't know. I I was going to shut this video off
after a little bit, but damn,
I want to know what the Mog incident is. Shockingly. Me, too.
>> Top right. Pisco recommended. Crazy. Crazy that happens.
I went to the bathroom to pee before lunch. I didn't really have
to go. I just wanted to do it proactively so I wouldn't have
to go later at a less optimal time. I'm extremely shy. I hate
the idea of peeing next to someone at a urinal. It feels so embarrassing
and the pee never comes out. Anyone else have this? So, I always
go to the stall to pee this. Oh god. Time. It's me and this.
He walks into the stall next to me. I start my pee stream and
it's kind of quiet and weak. I can tell. gay. >> The BBC
is laughing at my subhuman stream. He whips it out and produces
the most girthful and powerful stream I've >> Oh my god.
>> The most girthful and powerful stream I've ever experienced.
>> Experienced mogs me to Gandandy with his beautiful,
luscious stream. I truly want to end it. Indeed, that is a fate
worse than death. Cloud was clearly becoming more serious about
his looks maxing efforts now as he started taking more drugs,
including a daily dose of erectile dysfunction pills and looking
into preemptively taking osteoporosis meds to try to grow his
bones. At the same time, his online activity and his real life
once again began to mix together. He was keeping lidocaine, a
local anesthetic, in his bedroom so that he could numb himself
while performing his procedures. His mom found it and was not
very pleased. She stole the package of lidocaine and I'm losing
my mind right now. I spent $40 and she took it because it's dangerous.
I tried to lie and she went on a blue pill rant about how I'm
not a doctor. I'm genuinely seething and raging like you wouldn't
believe right now. Now I have to find a way to buy it without
them knowing. As his parents started to dude,
>> I guess wouldn't you expect his parents to like be tracking
some of his social media and would they have no idea he's doing
any of this?
like he's getting pretty popular at this point. Seems kind of
crazy
>> at this point. They know >> he's straight up doing
surgery on himself and he's like >> I don't know what he
did to his forehead that he was like cutting into his forehead.
I guess he his parents are rich. Maybe they're just like super
absent. Who knows? To get wise to his schemes, he got a job as
a bouncer so that he could make his own money and then made a
plan to order steroids without anyone, not even his parents,
finding out. With this newfound ability to blast away without
a care in the world, it's at this point that he actually came
to terms with how far he had taken looks maxing. Was all of this
really worth it? The hundreds of posts of strangers online, the
constant worrying about people in real life finding out about
his strange habits, his parents' disappointment in his behavior.
He decided it was time to just give it all up, to walk away.
And that's the end of the video.
Just kidding. He started taking Tren, one of the most infamous
anabolic steroids due to how absolutely insane its effects are.
He even started promoting it on the forum. When someone claiming
to be 14 years old using the site asked what drugs they should
use, Clavvicular gave him a detailed list of what he thinks he
should take with this supposed 14-year-old simply replying, "Thank
you." Obviously, anyone can just lie about their age on any website,
so it's impossible to know if this was truly a kid or not. But
Clav himself had now gone from someone who was socially awkward
and wanted to improve his looks in early high school to a legal
adult who was promoting harmful steroid use to children. Keep
in mind, during this time period, Clav was downright bragging
that he didn't even lift. He just took steroids and then got
five times the results of quote natural subhuman dogs.
With the glass ceiling broken, all the oppressed groups shall
prosper, especially the most oppressed group of all, gamers.
His disdain for Jim Bros is so strong that he scoffed at how
they pose in the gym's mirror. Jim Bros are I just flex in a
handicap bathroom, if anything. Clab's ability to freewheel his
steroid. >> Dude, he's so Okay, I get why he's popular.
Okay,
the text posts are funny. If he can translate the text post into
like real life interactions, that's hilarious.
I believe like obviously he does actually do a bunch of this,
but >> some of those text posts are [__]
>> He's just flexing a handicap stall,
>> cycle, and also still attending classes created a bit
of a golden age in terms of his posts. And there are a lot of
funny threads from this period. For example, there's one where
he recommends self-induced laryngitis is a means to achieve a
mogger voice as well as his brave declaration that asking people
for pictures of their is not gay as long as it's to check for
aesthetics. As far as his own, he provided updated measurements
claiming that his routines had produced an increase of 75 in.
Although, I do wonder if he's still getting fogged in the bathroom.
There's also one instance of him asking some guy what his mom's
poop smelled like, which I'm not really sure about the motivation
behind. I guess not every post can be a gem, which includes his
response to a thread asking looks maxing users what they think
about predator catchers on YouTube with Clav himself replying,
"Awful, bro. It's literal entrapment to ask incels to even if
they are underage, they never got that treatment, so it's unexpected
to them." He felt so strongly about this topic that he even went
as far as to make an entire thread about it. Although it is worth
noting that in the thread he does say he thinks texting minors
inappropriately is wrong. Regardless of whatever was h >> that's
big that's huge >> happening on the forum as long as that
was the only place he was posting. Clab knew that his reach would
be limited. So as terms like mogging and muing became more popular
parts of the modern internet's vocabulary he began exploring
new avenues to become a bonafide internet celebrity. In June
2024, we have one of the first instances of Clab going viral
online with this picture which was reposted to Reddit and then
>> Dude, I'm sorry. Him. This is also genius. I remember
this is in another video we watched with him and his grandma.
Grandma taking this picture for him. Is this real? This is 100%
real. This is like he's doing the blend. Okay.
He's like a significantly more successful Darius where it's like
yeah the bits like really him but it's like leaned into 30% so
it's a bit like he's saying it's a bit it looks like a bit but
it's not quite a bit cuz he's still doing it really
dude this hilarious viral online with this picture which was
reposted to Reddit and then Twitter after he had first posted
it to the Looks Max forum. Now, if you've been on 4chan or other
sites for a long time, you might be thinking to yourself that
you've seen this way before June 2024. That's because Clab's
picture is most likely a rehash of this old meme from the 4chan
fit board, which was also reposted a ton over the years. But
Clab's version would see a much more W. >> Dude, Clab's
version, his grandma literally doesn't have a neck. His grandma
is like [__] Mitch McConnell in a wig. That makes
it way better.
>> this is working out how to the
>> Sorry. This woman is fing figuring out how to kill the
filibuster and he's just mewing into the camera over here. Okay,
>> widespread appeal, getting nearly 12 million views on
Twitter and bringing him a lot closer to his goal of becoming
an online personality. Besides that, he was also getting some
interesting results in terms of his looks maxing. Despite having
to take three different meds to treat his erectile dysfunction
and use a pump, he claims he slept with nearly 100 women. Unfortunately,
this came with the side effect of being seen as someone who will
say anything and do anything in order to have sex with as many
women as possible. After a few months, it was increasingly hard
to continue picking up girls from his school. Naturally, this
led him to go back to doing what he does best, bragging and arguing
with random people on the forum to prove that he's an ascended
Chad. And although I thankfully haven't stumbled across it, he
claims >> Do any of you guys know like actual PUA types
who are actually psychopaths? And do you know why I know he isn't?
>> Lav question for you. >> Why? Why isn't this guy
a psychopath? >> Pickup artists like actual people who
do like pickup who just try to like game women into >> Do
you know what like the big difference
>> What do you think it is?
Well, I'm saying I know it is because I know a couple people
who are like this. Um Oh, >> so you're >> and it's
it's um >> you know everything about >> I don't I
don't know that they're I don't know that they're psychopaths.
I'm just saying that they will say anything [laughter] to women.
>> But um
>> they don't talk about it anywhere. They'll never like
tell you about it. They'll never ever cuz like a true like psychopath
is just calculated
or at least the people I've seen are just like calculated. They
don't talk about it. And also, you can basically just calculate
out social interactions, right? Like you like it's not hard to
figure out what you have to do. This guy's a he's not like he's
not Patrick Baitman. He's just a
>> I like Yeah, [clears throat] but you know, you realize
that like
autism and psychopathy are like
I mean they're sort of indistinguishable
when you're like a case like clavvicular
Psychopathy doesn't even really actually mean anything from a
psychological
>> Actually, people with like no concern about hurting
other people and are willing to say anything to get laid, but
also do it as like a long-term strategy. Wasn't trying to use
it as a psychological term. I was just using it as a descriptor.
>> Well, that's all it is is cuz a psychopath doesn't even
really
>> It's like kind of an innocuous thing. >> I get
it. You're like you're like just taking psych courses right now.
That's >> Yeah, I'm just taking psych courses. I like Okay.
[laughter] Like applying for my masters. Okay. I'm just taking
psych. You're right. >> Okay. You're finishing up a psych
degree. Congratulations.
>> Right. I'm just I'm just saying this is like widely
known and you don't even have you can just have Google to know
this. Like psychopath doesn't even mean
>> Sure. I think he's a psychopath conversation that you're
kind of >> colloquially you I just said that but yeah colloquially
yes he's a psychopath.
>> He's obviously just like severely >> Yeah.
I just feel like people >> he definitely has antisocial
traits. >> The way he presents himself the people who are
actually that way like they're just very calculated and they
don't like they don't let other people see the mask this easily.
Like he's into the social. the misconception that that people
who you think are psychopaths or antisocials are like very high
IQ like there it's this he could absolutely be diagnosed with
something like he could be antisocial. The the myth that like
every psychopath or sociopath or someone with antisocial is is
calculated is it's just a myth. It's just a myth.
>> it's the way he's presenting himself. He's like not
that way cuz I've seen people who are actually like him. No,
but it's the problem is that people hold up people with antisocial
in their head because they watch movies and they see true crime
and they think of Ted Bundy, people who are very calculated and
high IQ and they're like certainly everyone is is like this who
has these traits and it's just it's not most antisocials are
like this. You like you pity them. They're like you feel bad
for them. It's not like this big boogeyman who's like calculated
in like a kasanova. It's like most of them are just like really
socially awkward and like
weird and it gives and it gives people like fight or
cool. Cool. Cool.
>> Most of the people in jail are not most of them, but
a lot of people who are in prison who are felons are are antisocial
and
they're not all like
scholars. They're like gang members and like people who like
beat their wives to death and like
you know it doesn't take a lot. >> Okay. I wasn't thinking
about it on that deep a level but good background information
given we're watching a clvicular video.
>> Cool. Cool. We continue. I also don't know how much
of it is real
>> cuz he's memeing back and forth >> having on the
forum now I think is as good a time as any to talk about what
it means to ascend. There's an idea within looks back >> dude
got the peanut >> just straight up just straight up doing
a pump review at 18 years old that's
crazy time as any to talk about what it means to ascend. There's
an idea within looks maxing that at some point you have basically
achieved your ultimate goal of being at the highest possible
level of physical attractiveness at which point you can mog or
look better than anyone around you. >> I don't really give
a [__] about getting girls. I just want to mog like
mo do you guys mogging
>> means basically like looking better than
>> like so you want to mo like people
>> like dude like
>> because at the end of the day like with girls you could
just have
game status. It's just like everyone could do it at the end of
the day, but to actually [snorts] mog like you got to be >> Is
he
ranting to crackheads at a Popeye's or something? >> Oh
god. >> Okay, that's a hilarious bit, too. Just goes and
sits down at these random like
older women's table and just starts talking to them about how
good he looks. That's pretty funny.
>> Either genetically blessed or really work for it.
>> So that's what I'm trying to do. You may have noticed
that despite having entered college, there's basically no information
on what he was actually trying to get a degree in. That's because
it probably didn't matter to him at all. The most I was able
to find in direct relation to him going to college was when he
made a thread saying you could get college loans and then use
them to get plastic surgery. Although this is just one of many
threads he's made about getting loans for plastic surgery. Finally,
after months of doing nothing but having fun, his mom once again
found his roid stash. But this time he managed to convince her
to let him keep it with the argument that he's an adult and paid
for all of it himself. However, it's really important to say
that simply calling it a roid stash is not really correct. While
there were plenty of roids in there, Clav points out that there
was 1 kilogram of pregab. What he's referring to is the medication
pregabalin which is used to treat epilepsy and anxiety which
he had been taking in order to chemically make himself low inhib.
So he was basically taking it to feel less self-conscious and
high anxiety from the first
>> a kilogram.
>> If you have this guy's life, do the world a favor.
>> Do the world a favor and take a long drive off a short
bridge.
>> Dude, he had to have like a pill press right for that.
If you're a man with with high neuroticism to the point where
you have to drug yourself, >> just do the world a favor.
>> I will just be your pay. >> What this person this
person what this person actually has is auto gyophilia.
>> You're talking over a donation. This is like watching
a car wreck. Thank you, Ruben Ruben, for the $3. Lav will never
do that again to you, okay? She'll never talk over you donating
to the stream ever again. I can't hear them.
>> I can give you a link so you can hear
>> Well, I don't want to hear them. I'm just saying that
like I don't know when.
>> Well, I sorry. When I cut it and was like, "Hey, donation.
Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on." That was
the cue. >> Lav would still smash this psycho. No, I don't
like men like this. I'm actually extremely picky. my husband
and that's
>> I believe you to some extent, but
>> I don't I like guys who are like funny. That's the only
trait that I usually like. I don't I'm not I'm never looking
for someone who's like extremely
>> Ask Lav if she'll change her name to
>> No. [clears throat]
>> Without the C. Unlucky.
Laugh. You're married to a that literally eats tide pods. You're
not picky. I Well, he's funny. It makes me laugh.
I didn't say smart. >> I said funny.
>> Oh my god. Did you hear that story? Did you actually
Do you know that story? I'll tell it really, really quick. So,
I
>> Yeah, I cook. But Timmy will do the dishes. That's like
our thing is I'll cook him every meal, but he has to do the dishes
cuz I hate doing dishes.
So, we ran out of dish soap and I was like, "Oh, we like after
like two weeks, I was like, "What are you washing the dish soap
with?" Because I looked under the sink and there was no dish
soap. I was like, "What are you sending through the dishwasher?"
>> Dude, that's by the way, that's not even a good trade.
>> That's not a good trade. He's losing that trade.
>> Well, I cook him every meal and clean the whole house.
I think he can do the dishes and take out the trash. Those are
his only jobs. Um, I'm saying that if it it was like somebody
else cook, dude, cooking is fun and then doing the dishes is
the world. Doing the dishes is why nobody cooks.
>> Anyway, I was just saying >> uh maybe maybe I
don't mind doing the dishes if I'm doing them like right after
I cook something, but that's never the way that it pans out.
So like I don't want to touch like crusty anything. That's like
horrible. Um but
yeah, so I I was like, "So what are you washing the dishes with?"
And he goes, "Oh, the pods." And I was like, "The we're out of
pods." And he was like, "No, we're not stupid." And he literally
like he like knocks on my head calling me stupid. He's like,
"You're like dumb woman." And I'm like, "Okay, what do you mean?
Like we don't have pods left." And he's like, "The Tide pods."
I'm like, "You're joking." For 2 weeks, he'd been washing our
dishes with Tide Pods.
And he was like, "They're the same thing." No. And I was like,
"No, Tim.
>> No." [clears throat] So, yeah. That's my man. And I'mma
stick beside him. >> How? Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. There's
something that's not totally related to that, right? Like if
you had to in a pinch clean off dishes, then that technically
is soap that is usable, but I don't think it's like I think a
normal person would actually like just go to the store and get
more cascade. I >> Yeah, this is what literally everybody
else would do. Yeah. I'm saying I'm saying hypothetically you
could maybe do it, but like not knowing the difference is kind
of crazy. How do you >> No. And it's because he's he's
an only >> He live. >> He's an only son and I lived
out of the house for years. >> He literally lived out of
the house for
>> How did he survive? What was going on in that coupon
house? >> He did not do his laundry.
He was throwing Cascade in the laundry machine.
>> Like he I just don't even think he was doing his laundry
for a second. Kimmy was doing his laundry. >> What do you
mean? What do you mean I can't use Mr. Clean in the laundry machine?
What do you mean? >> Yeah. No, he just like
he's
I don't know. He's a He's He's the only son
and his mom's obsessed with him, so he never had to do anything.
>> What a crazy situation.
>> I'll just say I feel like I'm basically in that same
situation and I still learned how to do the laundry, but hey,
>> it's fine. >> You know, maybe maybe if if he was
a little older. He's he's 26 years old, so >> You know,
>> he's got time to learn. >> Yeah. Yeah, that's
my man.
>> Let's go. Nice. Speaking of intelligence, let's go to
the guy who is who's taking these who's self-prescribing these
meds. He must have his own pill press, right? You don't get a
kilogram of pills that are already pressed into pills. You get
like the capsules and you do the pill pressing yourself, right?
You do the powders and the pill pressing yourself. I think so.
>> First day he went to college, he was dosing himself
with pregabalin and blephin. Now, unlike pregab, which has more
psychological effects, blephin is a straightup muscle relaxing
that while not a benzo, has similar withdrawal results because
of how strong it can be. His reason for taking these is so that
he can cold approach girls constantly as he claims he's unable
to do so otherwise. Interestingly, he eventually evolved his
stack to also include beer. From now on, I will drink a beer
of some kind every 90 minutes. I haven't decided which one I'll
drink, but more than likely an IPA since it's high calories.
The ethanol will intoxicate me to make me low inhib and happy.
The intoxication will be subtle, so it's good to do at work and
you can still be giga productive. I'll just sprinkle one mill.
Dude, this is the uh this is the plot of that Mads Mickelson
movie. I've never watched that, by the way, and I do want to
watch it. You ever seen that movie,
>> I forget. Is it literally just called
>> Uh, hold on. Mads Mikkelson
drunk. It's like the plot line of that. Is it literally just
called? It is just called drunk. Okay, another round is the English
title. Check this trailer. Movie seems like it'd be so good.
Probably subtitles, right?
These guys basically all have this discussion, okay?
And they're like, "You know what? Let's just try getting lit
like 247.
>> Hold on. Give it a second.
I'm so thrilled right now. [singing]
It's Listen,
I'm sure nobody's ever fallen down this dude. Actually, being
intoxicated feels great. And I'm like, it's always awesome. I'm
just going to take a little bit more. I'm just going to take
a little bit more.
We are beautiful.
What a night.
What a beautiful [singing]
>> I don't know. I It always the the trailers the whole
movie. Oh, yeah. I don't know. Like you could It's predictable
how it would go. It just looked like it was fun. Like a fun movie.
Did they actually drink? I have no idea if they actually drank
for the roles. Maybe. What language are they speaking? Finnish.
Probably Dutch, actually. Hold on. Let me see. Uh,
hold on. Uh, another round. IMDb. Go, go, go. I think either
Dutch or Norwegian, right? Whoa. Or I get the language. I can't
tell. >> Beer paper. >> Thought it was Norwegian.
>> Reuben donated $3. It was either donos or alcoholism.
>> Well, I'm happy
that you chose donos and not alcoholism. Is it Danish?
Denmark. Produced in Denmark. That's what I said first cuz he
is Danish, right? Mads Mickelson. Yeah, Danish
>> Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool. All right, back
to this clvicular video. Basically, same concept. Okay, same
concept. Just going to get a little drunk most of the time. >> Milligram
of aroma sin into each beer to counter the estrogen. The only
bad side effect of beer maxing. Number one,
low inhib. It didn't take long for him to announce in a thread
that he had grown to basically do nothing all day but drink and
try to get with women all while asking the forum for more ideas
of drugs he could take with his own suggestions being or nicotine.
We're going to come back. Oh
I've got a coder friend who is like
guy guy's got like 10 of his own startups. He's like a multi-millionaire
at at 30 retired.
He swears by nicotine. When he has like a deadline, like a crunch,
he will go get like 10 boxes of nicotine patches and wallpaper
himself the whole time. He's like, it's incredible. And the focus
level you get is insane. I never tried it, but it's hard to I
I get the feeling that the way I felt about it was I was like,
you're just probably like a genius who does this to
because like it it's just your thing, but you probably would
be fine either
Yeah, I'm not going to do it. But I'm just like, uh, what was
the other thing he say? Oh, he used to order um Oh, he used to
order
poppy seeds
and then soak them to try to get like something some pseudo LSD
out of them, I think, was like the thing he used to do. He would
like soak them and then like
like suck on them like they're candy or something. I forget.
Is it LSA? LSA. People are saying LSA.
I I have no idea. Okay, this guy was uh this guy was wild. You
You meet a lot of weird people in tech that are just like I'm
actually gonna They're basically kicular for but for their brains.
Okay, going to take whatever stack they can.
One of them almost convinced me to do what is it? Oh, it's like
Oh, micro doing LSD micro doing. I never got into it. >> Yeah,
I never got into it, but they did. They thought it was cool.
You ever hear people take mad modafanil? Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope.
Micro doing is shrooms over LSD. I think the shrooms the problem
with shrooms for micro doing was the dosing can be a little more
difficult. With LSD it's easy with like vodka to get the doses
like 100% on on point. But with shrooms it can be a little more
difficult. I think was what I'd heard.
They're a poly market bet for clvicular getting charged.
Poly market
clavvicular.
Yep. Clvicular charge. By the way, they should pay me if I'm
going to be doing this, but clavvicular charge by Jan 31.
26% chance. It was like 50. Now it's down a lot.
Interesting. Wow. I grew mushrooms under my bed and ate them
by the handful. I micro do sometimes, but I would just always
prefer aderall. And if this guy were actually smart, he'd have
a just got a prescription, which is easy.
I think a lot of incelss basically think
the medical profession is and that they give you like really
doses of things and so they always look to do it themselves so
they can actually do the dosing
Yeah. Here give me one second. I will hit play on this video.
I'll be right back. Give me two minutes tops. >> Back to
the thing later. But to the surprise of no one, his first criminal
charges came soon after he began more conventional drug use.
In August 2024, he was charged with misdemeanor assault and battery
on a 56-year-old woman, as well as felony assault and battery
on a 63-year-old man. Kiwi Farms user, Colonel Sugarlemons, was
the one who dumped all the information related to this case.
The story goes that around 11 p.m. an altercation broke out over
two members of a large wedding party who were allegedly pulling
on bras hanging from the ceiling in the bar area. Clav approached
them, told them to stop, and they initiated a fight, leading
to an all-out brawl. So far, not really anything unreasonable
from Clav, but it appears that during the chaos, he was throwing
punches at someone's mom, the 56-year-old woman listed in the
charges. Now, I am going to say here that he most likely didn't
do it on purpose, especially since these charges were dropped.
However, I also
>> the 56-year-old woman listed in the charges. Now, I
am going to
[laughter] what say here that he most likely didn't do it on
purpose. It showed him smashing her back up. Wait, >> Information
related to this case. The story goes that around 11 p.m. an altercation
broke out over two members of a large wedding party who were
allegedly pulling on bras hanging from the ceiling in the bar
area. Clav approached them, told them to stop, and they initiated
a fight leading to an all-out brawl. So far, not really anything
unreasonable from Clav, but it appears that during the chaos,
he was throwing punches at someone's mom, the 56-year-old woman
listed in the charges. Now I am going to >> I didn't see
it there. >> Say here >> I've said he hit a woman
not a man and that he might sue Tom man. >> He most likely
didn't do it on purpose especially since these charges were dropped.
However, I also think it's likely that his employer was to an
outl
approached them told them allegedly as
or nicotine. We're going to come back to the meth thing later.
But to the surprise of no one, his first criminal charges came
soon after he began more conventional drug use. In August 2024,
he was charged with misdemeanor assault and battery on a 56-y
old use. In August
>> charged with >> that looks like a dude. >> Came
soon after he began more conventional drug use. In August 2024,
he was
charged with misdemeanor assault and battery on a 56y old woman
as well as felony assault and battery on a 63y old. >> Looks
like the WOMAN THERE. OH, WAIT. Who did he clock right there?
Okay, that could be a 60. [laughter] He just clocked the [__]
out of that woman.
Jesus. To be fair,
that's a demon. Okay, >> that's a demon. What the [__]
Hello. Is that a demon? >> Oh, that's your that's your
sound reverbing. Okay. >> Old man. Kiwi Farms user Colonel
Sugarlemons was the one who dumped all the information related
to this case. The story. >> Oh no. Oh no. Unfortunately,
what Tom doesn't realize here is um he actually just signed up
to be doxed and harass
referencing Kiwi Farms. You guys
that Turkey Tom just obviously signed up to be doxed and harassed
because he referenced Kiwi Farms, right? That's the logic we're
all running with now, right?
Totally. Totally. Totally. >> Story goes that around >> Oh,
did I cut my own audio out there in the middle of speaking? I
might have >> 11 p.m. an altercation broke out over two
members of a large wedding party who were allegedly pulling on
bras hanging from the ceiling in the bar area. Clab approached
them, told them to stop, and they initiated a fight, leading
to
>> Clav threatening to sue apparently Turkey Tom. Levicular
responds to YouTuber Turkey Tom and says he's >> okay just
even those statements right there especially when it's uh you
know clearly against like
you know well documented because you look at all the police reports
none of this even happened. I didn't get charged for
um for anything to do with a woman. We could pull it up right
now and it was assault and battery on two men. So, the fact that
you even make statements that are of that definitive nature,
I could sue this guy right now. >> I saw the paperwork
in my own eyes.
>> y'all never learn. Willie Mack is calling Tom right
now yelling, "You are calling for Tom's docks."
Oh, well, he could do that. Tom is a little more discerning.
Tom has, you know, basic literacy, like he can read, you know,
at a fifth grade level at minimum, unlike Willie Mack. So Tom
would just watch this and be like, "Oh, he's saying that as a
joke, as a tongue-in-cheek thing about somebody who's currently
on a doxing campaign against him and his
>> Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, um, like what the
that's actually something to even look into.
>> Is that relevant?
Wait, did I miss somebody else you guys are clearly talking about?
That's not who who is the who's asking if this is a
No shot, right? No. Is that Really? There. I missed it. There's
somebody else who flashed on screen who's not this guy who you
guys were asking if that was Really, right?
There's like multiple people who just asked if this was Rei.
There has to be another guy that popped up somewhere
to look into because it's like you can't just you can't just
have a 1.6 6 million subscriber page posting to 700,000 people
and make things up that I I punched a woman. Like, are you insane?
So, um, views.
He's not suing anybody.
>> An allout brawl. So far, not really anything unreasonable
from Clav, but it appears that during the chaos, he was throwing
punches at someone's mom, the 56-year-old woman listed in the
charges. Now, I am going to say here that he most likely didn't
do it on purpose, especially since these charges were >> Wait,
Turkey Tom has gotten information wrong all the time in his videos.
>> Yeah, I don't doubt that. I I don't doubt that. Uh what
I would doubt is whether or not Clav's going to sue him.
However, I also think it's likely that his employer wasn't aware
that one of his bouncers was regularly drunk and drugged up to
the gills while on the shift. If any legal situation like this
happens and for whatever reason Clav gets tested for drugs, he
is an automatic liability and is a lot more likely to be considered
culpable. But regardless, he got away with being an alcoholic
pre. >> Dude, does the Death Note Animation Studio just
never copyright their own music. I feel like everybody uses the
>> Gabin and Blephin Fiend. Ironically enough, what he
didn't get away with was the steroids. After getting his mom
to stop giving him grief over his looks maxing, his activity
on the forum would finally catch up to him when another user
sent his post history to his >> I was uh kicked out of
Uni for essentially roid maxing and uh you know looks maxing,
whatever the term you want to use is. Unfortunately, someone
decided to archive all of my posts and uh
apparently find out where I went to to univer >> I don't
even believe this.
I actually don't believe this at all.
Um I feel like it's way more likely that he just wanted to drop
out of school and didn't like being in school and didn't want
to pay for school and then he just
Right. Did he post any proof of this? I feel like I'm immediately
going to say fake until proven otherwise. That's my guess. All
right. Maybe it just gets proven out in the video. I've seen
it. >> And uh send them all to the public safety uh at
my university
detailing all my alleged uh activities which prompted them uh
the university to do a search of my room and uh uncover certain
looks maxing peptides and you know things like uh hormones and
you know TRT whatnot. in uh this Chestered clown world of America
that's illegal.
>> Hold on. I will say
apparently he talked about helping other people and charging
people to give them stuff like this and give them advice on stuff
like this. If that's what he was actually doing and it was like
a threat to other students basically that he was going to give
advice to them, prescribe things to them, I definitely could
see how they kick him out for sure. >> Cool. Uh testosterone
is illegal, guys. you're not actually allowed to do it without
a uh extremely gestured prescription that I can't afford. I don't
have health insurance.
So, I was using underground labs to source testosterone. Like,
I'm sorry, but I can't afford uh to go through like some of these
online clinics or like an
you know what I mean? Like, I'm a broke 18-year-old
and I live at home.
>> Bro, you your parents are rich as
Also, you're reverbing a lot. >> They're probably They're
probably not going to Oh,
>> His parents are probably not going to support his drug
habit, though. It doesn't matter how much his parents >> I
mean, the reason he can't go to his doctor, which he could totally
do, and his parents have health insurance that he would qualify
under 100%, especially if he's still in university. Okay. He
would 100% qualify under that until like a certain age, right?
You have no >> Yeah. He doesn't need testosterone, right?
They're not going to give you all these things. >> Yeah,
exactly. But that's what he that's what he's saying. He's saying,
"Oh, I can't afford it." It's like, "Yeah, you could afford it.
You're just not going to get prescribed. If you go to any sane
doctor, they're going to go, "Oh, if you're 18, what the [__]
are you talking about? You're out of your mind." Like, I'm actually
prescribing you
therapy. I'm going to prescribe you therapy cuz you need therapy
badly. >> Home, you know, with my grandma. So, it's like
to go ahead and go through the legal route.
uh and spend all this extra money rather than just source it
on my own. Just seemed incredibly
uh gestured to me and that's why I went ahead and made the decision.
[snorts] >> On one hand, I honestly do feel bad for >> I'm
guessing when he's saying gestured, he means like uh they're
clowns, right? That's a that's a thing, right? Gesture maxing
being gesture builds. They're he's calling it like a clown world.
It's obviously a joke situation. Yeah. Am I translating correctly,
guys? Clav, it's not a good thing to maliciously contact the
college with the intent of harming him in some way. That kind
of behavior never comes from a good place. With that being said,
he really really did everything in his power to allow this to
happen for making almost no effort to separate his personal life.
>> Why would you cultivate this jawline and then also cultivate
that facial hair? That is a travesty.
That is actually disgusting.
What? What was the point? what was the >> power to allow
this to happen. From making almost no effort to separate his
personal life from his looks maxing endeavors to outright bragging
about his very questionable activity on campus which included
him saying he was going to do DIY Botox injections on other
>> that that'll be why they would have kicked him out if
that really if he really was kicked out and reported or something.
this will be what led to him getting reported is like, "Hey,
this guy's literally going to advertise like doing Botox injections
and other to other students again >> among many other things."
Even if the only thing that got him in trouble was the testosterone
he had, he claims he doesn't get it legally because he can't
afford health insurance. But at the same time, he has a dozen
threads about how much money he's planning to dump into plastic
surgeries. So, I'm not sure how sincere that is. His focus on
the importance of looks maxing comes through pretty clearly as
just moments after remarking about how mean-spirited people online
can be, he's describing being kicked out as a blessing in disguise.
>> Now I am able to fully uh dedicate my time to look maxing.
So I think this is going to wind up being a blessing in the >> The
end of college would also mark the end of any normaly for Clav.
He was now fully committed to becoming a popular >> I mean
he did kind of pop off >> looks maxing influencer. His
next video is titled I started trend at 18 and so should you.
Which should really give you an idea of what kind of approach
he was now embracing. Within just a few months of being kicked
out, you can clearly see how much further he was going into the
abyss. Getting an $86 pump, getting on multiple weight loss drugs
like Mojaro and DNP, and on top of that partying. During these
parties, he would do coke along with drinking alcohol and taking
blephin. Not to mention the other stuff he was already taking,
such as steroids. >> wait. This is rough, isn't it? Like
muscle relaxants plus um alcohol.
I I feel like this is a really dangerous mix. No, I think these
are like horrible to mix. No. Bills, etc. Obviously, even by
normal partying standards, this is a pretty impressive. And these
habits would eventually lead him to crash his car. Body cam footage
of the aftermath has been released and we can see that he basically
drove into a ditch on a narrow road, but that's much less informative
than what Clap himself said in a post about the incident. I was
nodding off on the way home and crashed into a fence. It'll cost
me at least 2 to three grand. Surgery delayed once again. The
cops didn't care that I was intoxicated. I'm boys with them.
We work out of the gym. It's interesting that his greatest concern
was not that he could have hurt someone or hurt himself. His
main priority was that the crash was delaying one of his many
planned surgeries. The first reply this thread got is someone
pointing out that he could have taken the life of an innocent
person while driving in that state, which honestly restored my
faith in this website a bit overall. For any reasonable person,
this would be a wake-up call to, you know, not be strung out
on everything all the time. Maybe a lifestyle change. But for
Cleb, it was just another obstacle to his ascension. Now that
he was getting more attention online through Tik Tok and these
minor scandals, Cleb decided it was time to cash in a bit. If
you're tired of being invisible to women, tired of getting rejected,
and tired of watching other guys who won the genetic lottery
take what's yours, then pay attention because what I'm about
to show you will completely transform your face and physique
in ways that you didn't even think were possible. Look, I'm not
going to sugarcoat this. You have been lied to. They told you
just be confident, just be yourself. Looks don't matter. But
you and I both know that's complete bull. >> Yeah. He opened
a coaching page where he charges people $49 every month to have
access to his methods. I'm not sure how much money this page
was making when it started, but the landing page claims to have
1,500 members, which could add up to quite a bit of money. Now,
I usually try not to hate on someone's bag too much. After all,
I am a believer in good old American capitalism. But given the
advice that we've seen him give out to people so far, my hopes
for this school are pretty low. But with the money coming in,
he posted on Looks Max saying he filled out a loan application
for surgery, specifically Maxilla surgery. This is surgery that
will radically restructure his face and is another step in his
quest to ascend. His post around this time also got even more
questionable. In one post, he writes about how he makes sure
that he explodes inside of the better-l lookinging girls he's
been with to pass on his jeans. Hopefully, we don't get a low
tier god situation here. >> SAY IT [laughter] LOUDER THAN
MY CHILD. >> AND another post that's definitely
>> Say it loud.
>> Kind of interesting that Tom's willing to take this
shot and
not other shots. Very curious, ISN'T IT? >> I'VE ABANDONED
MY CHILD. [screaming] IN ANOTHER POST THAT'S definitely trolling,
he criticizes people who wash their ass, calling it gay. As 2025
approached, he found himself wondering why all the women left
around him were extremely
>> Oh, you you know that this guy was like a massive Zirka
fan, right?
This guy's like a Zirka super fan. >> Oh, Lav's Yeah. Okay.
Sorry. I was like, "Oh, Lav's probably asleep actually."
>> Was a huge Zirkavan. Zirka super fan. literally some
guy he he went on some podcast with the I think it was with Walter
like Fresh from Fresh and Fit and then Walter's numerologist
I guess and the numerologist was talking Zirka because apparently
he used to be Zurka's manager and Clav was like actually just
tearing him down for on Yeah. Gary
um Clav was just on him for talking [__] about Zirka.
It was very very very funny.
>> Good stuff. and then revealed that he is now in $50,000
worth of medical debt, which he has no intention of paying off.
Could he be lying about some of these details? Sure. But the
overall point still stands. The shark has been jumped and he
is past the point of no return here. His delusions go so far
that he went to an orthodontist and began quote dropping nuclear
black pills on him. All to walk out with $7,500 worth of Invisalign
to fix his teeth because apparently that's something he's very
insecure about. Another thing he's never managed to figure out
with his drug stacks is his facial hair, which eventually led
him to draw a mustache on with an eyebrow pencil because according
to him, it makes him look like a dad. I really hope stuff like
this in particular is trolling due to how downright stupid this
looks. Like clockwork, Clav has some brief moments where he attempts
to produce something resembling self-awareness and makes the
Hold on. Uh, what is this? December 20th. Wait, is this what
we were looking for earlier?
This might be what we were looking for earlier. Hold on. Clip.
Quick clip from Clav Groper. Clvicular Groper. Clvicular gets
accused of druging girls by guy whose whose girl cheated on
>> What? What' you say?
>> What' you say to me? >> You [__] our
friend got drugged at >> No. What the [__]
did you say? >> What did I say? >> What the [__]
did you say? >> What did I say? >> Tell me what [laughter]
you said. Right. Say it.
>> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Sorry, I hit spacebar. Somebody
find Z now. I found a new H. Dude, get this person and Z together,
[laughter] >> bro. What the What is this?
>> What did I say? >> Tell me what you said. Say
it again. >> What did I say? >> No, just just repeat
yourself. >> What did I say? >> Did you say clav
drugs girls? Are you
>> You said that
table. >> Are you the dead a couple weeks ago? >> The
dead? Oh god. They're like all
>> They're like all Oh no. >> The den. >> Holy
[__] >> I've never had a a table in my life
at the den. You >> have, bro. We [__] there.
>> I've been at other people's tables. I've never had a
table in my life. >> It was a [__] friend table.
>> Listen to me. Listen to me. If you think I've ever shut
the [__] up. >> Yeah. If you think me I didn't
do
>> If you think I would ever do some [__] like
that, dude, that is not a good
You can't walk around saying [__] like that.
Get Get out of the way.
>> Listen to me. You You can't just go around saying things
>> and expect things to go well for you. You know what
I mean? >> I know I know you think we do live streaming,
but I'm high as I don't give a [__] >> What
are you high off, dog? >> I'm high off ketamine. So, if
you think I give a about the live stream, I don't. I'm telling
you. >> So, don't go around making these accusations. You
know what I mean? It's not a good idea. >> It's not a good
It's not a good idea. Is has Clvicular fought somebody on stream
>> What are you doing? >> His jawline does suck.
That's brutal. He's getting jaw mogged.
>> This is surgery right on this guy.
>> I'm pressing you for making a
>> He just has a good jawline. What do you
>> You are coping right now. >> What am I coping?
>> Maybe. He's like sticking his jaw out then. He's sticking
his jaw out. >> You are coping. You are literally
>> I'm sorry that No, this is some goofy [__]
right here. >> Saying I drug people. Are you >> [__]
got drugged at the table you're >> At the table I was at.
So, it's my >> Hey yo, go somewhere else. He's the one
pressing the [__] out of here. Get the
>> Hey, look. Y'all got to go over here, man. Y'all got
to go over here. Everybody got to go over there, man. I don't
want the cops to come over here. >> That's what I'm saying,
bro.
I take all the drugs. I I am the one who takes all the drugs.
You know what I'm saying? It's like you're
like I want the drugs in my system. Give me them.
>> That's not the best defense I've ever seen on somebody
saying you drug people.
[laughter] I WANT ALL THE DRUGS. WHY WOULD I GIVE OTHER PEOPLE
the drugs? >> If you think I would drug anyone but take
the drugs myself, you're a
>> Um, wait. Am I coming home with you? >> Yeah.
I hope that girl [__] dies. >> That seems slightly
excessive.
>> Is the guy everybody said was irrelevant, by the way.
This guy right
Actual racist in the chat. It >> is irrelevant.